One of my favorite things to do with my family is to go on a road trip. We are road trippers. Josh and I love to pack up the car and hit the road with our kids. And I just love the sense of adventure of exploring new places. And we love to use Airbnb. We love staying in a home. We love having a kitchen, having some type of backyard, our patio to sit on at night.
我和家人最喜欢做的事情之一就是去公路旅行。我们是公路旅行爱好者。乔什和我喜欢收拾好车，带着孩子们上路。我非常喜欢探索新地方的那种冒险感。我们还喜欢用 Airbnb。我们喜欢住在家里。我们喜欢有厨房，有某种后院或露台，晚上可以坐在那里。
I love the privacy of it. And also it just feels like you're still at home even though you're on this adventure because you make your own home. And you know, Airbnb is just so great for families because you can really pick a place that suits your whole group. You know, we did that one year with my family.
我喜欢它的私密性。而且，尽管你在进行这场冒险，但感觉就像还在家里一样，因为你可以营造出自己的家。你知道，Airbnb 对家庭来说真是太棒了，因为你真的可以挑选一个适合你们整个团体的住处。你知道，我有一年和我的家人就是这样做的。
We all met up in the mountains and picked this great Airbnb and all stayed in it together. Cousins and nieces and nephews and aunts and uncles. It was so much fun and it was so cozy. And Airbnb really made that family memory special. So use Airbnb for your next adventure. With the Fizz loyalty program, you get rewarded just for having a mobile plan.
我们都在山里集合，选了这个很棒的 Airbnb，然后住在一起。表亲、侄女、侄子、阿姨和叔叔们。那真的非常有趣，也非常温馨。Airbnb 确实让那个家庭记忆变得特别。所以，下次冒险时也用 Airbnb 吧。有了 Fizz 忠诚度计划，你只需拥有一个移动套餐就能获得奖励。
You know, for texting and stuff. And if you're not getting rewards like extra data and dollars off with your mobile plan, you're not with Fizz. Switch today. Conditions apply. Details at fizz.ca. Grab your life preservers, everyone. Get ready to set sail. Today we are taking a second drink of booze cruise. This was such a fun breakdown. Do you remember, Jenna, we had Greg Daniels in the studio with us for the whole thing. Yes. He was so excited, remember? He was like, I have a time code.
你知道，就是发短信之类的。如果你的移动套餐没有获得额外流量和现金抵扣等奖励，那你用的就不是 Fizz。今天就换过来吧。适用相关条款。详情请见 fizz.ca。大家抓好救生圈。准备起航了。今天我们要对《酒船之旅》进行第二次深入探讨。这集拆解太有趣了。珍娜，你还记得吗，格雷格·丹尼尔斯全程都在录音室陪着我们。是的。他当时非常兴奋，记得吗？他说，我有一个时间码。
Yes, yes. And it was his first time being on Office Ladies. It was very special. And I felt like we covered this episode so well. We also wrote an entire chapter about it in our book, Office BFFs, with tons of behind-the-scenes pictures that we took. But I did find a couple of things that we could mention here.
是的，是的。这是他第一次参加《办公室女士》节目。这非常特别。我觉得我们对这一集的解读非常到位。我们还在书《办公室闺蜜》中专门写了一整章关于它的内容，里面有我们拍的大量幕后照片。但我确实发现了一些我们可以在这里提到的事情。
Okay, first off, we talked about Mindy's play, Matt and Ben, that she did with her friend, Brenda Withers, who appears in this episode. This is what got Mindy discovered. And we got this comment from Christine A., who said, Google Matt and Ben Mindy Kaling and the full show comes up on YouTube. Questionable legality, but it's there. So if you wanted to follow up and watch it, there you go.
好的，首先，我们谈到了明迪的戏剧《马特和本》，那是她和朋友布伦达·威瑟斯一起演的，布伦达也出现在了这一集中。正是这部剧让明迪被发掘。我们收到了克里斯汀·A 的评论，她说，在谷歌搜索“Matt and Ben Mindy Kaling”，YouTube 上就有完整的演出视频。虽然合法性存疑，但确实能找到。所以如果你想跟进观看的话，就在那里。
It's very grainy. But I also found a paperback version of the play on Amazon, Angela. What? Yes, it's been published and it has 4.7 stars out of 5. That's very highly rated. Very highly rated. I think, you know, if you're an aspiring writer, maybe reading it would be like a good research
画面非常模糊。但我还在亚马逊上找到了这出戏的平装本，安吉拉。什么？是的，它已经出版了，而且在 5 分满分中获得了 4.7 星。评价非常高。评价非常高。我想，如果你是一个有抱负的作家，也许读读它会是一个很好的研究。
or something. Well, another thing we talked a lot about was the Jim and Pam 27 Seconds of Silence. Yes. We recently got a letter from Caio from Brazil. Caio, I hope I'm saying your name correctly. They write, the 27 seconds of silence in Boo's Cruise may hold the record for the longest moment of silence in a comedy, but I was just watching the West Wing episode from season seven called Here Today, and I think that might take the cake. When Tony confesses
或者类似的东西。嗯，我们谈论很多的另一件事是吉姆和帕姆那 27 秒的沉默。是的。我们最近收到了一封来自巴西的卡约的信。卡约，希望我没念错你的名字。他们写道，在《酒船之旅》中那 27 秒的沉默可能保持着喜剧中最长沉默时刻的纪录，但我刚才在看《白宫风云》第七季中名为《今日在此》的那一集，我觉得那集可能更胜一筹。当托尼向 CJ 坦白
to CJ that he leaked the space shuttle story, there is a whopping 56.9 seconds of silence between when CJ says they can't talk until the council's office shows up and when the lawyer finally does talk almost a full minute. That is wild. Wow. Wow. Okay. We did 27 seconds of silence. West Wing did almost a full minute. It makes me want to go watch that scene. It does. Me too. That was a long time.
他泄露了航天飞机的故事时，从 CJ 说“在议会办公室出现之前他们不能谈话”到律师最终开口，中间有整整 56.9 秒的沉默，几乎是一整分钟。这太疯狂了。哇。哇。好吧。我们做了 27 秒的沉默。《白宫风云》做了几乎一整分钟。这让我很想去看看那一幕。确实。我也是。那真是太久了。
Me too. There's got to be so much playing out on their faces in that minute. Yeah. Thank you for writing in their faces in that minute. Yeah. Thank you for writing in. I thought that was so interesting. Well, finally, Kaylee Kay commented on this episode, quote, I know the extra that jumped from the boat in Booze Cruise. His name is R.C. Ormond, and he's a stunt actor in Los Angeles. Oh, that's fantastic.
我也是。在那一分钟里，他们的脸上一定闪过了很多情绪。是的。谢谢你的来信。我觉得这太有趣了。嗯，最后，凯莉·凯评论了这一集，引用如下：“我认识那个在《酒船之旅》中跳船的临时演员。他的名字叫 R.C. 奥蒙德，他是洛杉矶的一名特技演员。”哦，那太棒了。
Kaylee, thank you so much. I found his credit. He is listed as Panicked Man. And according to his bio, he has appeared as both an actor and stunt man in a wide range of productions, from Transformers and The Time Machine to the TV miniseries The Fugitive. I liked this nugget from his bio. His first professional acting job was in the Batman stunt show at Six Flags Over Texas as a teenager. How about that? I love those stunt shows.
凯莉，非常感谢。我找到了他的演职员表。他被列为“惊慌失措的人”。根据他的个人简介，他作为演员和特技演员出现在广泛的作品中，从《变形金刚》和《时间机器》到电视迷你剧《亡命天涯》。我喜欢他简介里的这个小花絮。他十几岁时第一份专业表演工作是在德克萨斯六旗乐园的蝙蝠侠特技表演中。怎么样？我喜欢那些特技表演。
I know. There's a really good one at Universal Studios. Yeah. I know. Well, we went one step further, and we reached out to RC because I wanted to ask him about that experience of jumping in the water. Yeah. Here's what he said. He said, so what's really crazy to me because I wanted to ask him about that experience of jumping in the water.
我知道。环球影城有一个非常棒的。是的。我知道。嗯，我们更进一步，联系了 RC，因为我想问问他跳进水里的那种经历。是的。这是他说的。他说，对我来说真正疯狂的是，因为我想问问他跳进水里的那种经历。
Yeah. Here's what he said. He said, So what's really crazy to me is that we filmed that episode 20 years ago. At the time, I was a big fan of the show. We filmed it in the middle of winter in Rainbow Harbor in Long Beach. It was a night shoot, and by the time they got to my scene, it was about one in the morning. Yeah.
是的。这是他说的。他说，对我来说真正疯狂的是，我们拍摄那一集已经是 20 年前的事了。当时，我是该剧的忠实粉丝。我们在长滩的彩虹港拍摄，当时正值隆冬。那是夜间拍摄，当他们拍到我的场景时，大约是凌晨一点。是的。
That water was freezing. I bet. He said, I was wearing a wetsuit under my clothes, and it was still cold. He went on to share, I remember when we were setting up the scene, a lot of the background actors, and even some of the series regulars, started asking me questions like, hey,
那水冷得要命。我敢肯定。他说，我衣服里面穿了潜水服，但还是很冷。他接着分享道，我记得当我们布置场景时，很多背景演员，甚至一些剧组常驻演员，开始问我问题，比如，嘿，
are you the stunt guy that's jumping off the boat? Is the water cold? Are you scared? Can you swim? All great questions, he said. All that to say, if I had to narrow my experience down to one quote, this would be it. It was one of the coolest, most exhilarating and chilling experiences I've ever had. That describes all of it. If I had the opportunity to do it all over again, I totally would in a heartbeat. That's how much fun I had on that show. It was pretty awesome.
你是那个要跳船的特技演员吗？水冷吗？你害怕吗？你会游泳吗？都是很好的问题，他说。总而言之，如果我必须把我的经历浓缩成一句话，那就是：这是我经历过的最酷、最令人振奋但也最寒冷的体验之一。这描述了一切。如果我有机会重来一次，我绝对会毫不犹豫地去做。我在那个节目里玩得太开心了。这真是太棒了。
And then he added, just to be clear, I hate cold water with the passion of a thousand suns. But to be blessed with the opportunity to work on that show, I didn't even care. And he noted, we got the shot in two takes. So he only had to do it twice. Well, I just looked up the average temperature of Rainbow Harbor in the winter. It's about 57 degrees.
然后他补充说，澄清一下，我极其讨厌冷水。但能有幸在那部剧中工作，我根本不在乎。他指出，我们拍了两条就过了。所以他只需要跳两次。嗯，我刚查了冬天彩虹港的平均温度。大约是 57 华氏度（约 14 摄氏度）。
That's about what my cold dip is set on. That's cold. That's cold. And who knows what it is at midnight. Yeah, exactly. Well, you know, Jenna, we also got a comment from CKFresh522, who wrote in to say, there is footage of RC jumping in the water
那差不多就是我冷水浴设定的温度。那很冷。那很冷。谁知道午夜时分是多少度。是的，没错。嗯，你知道吗，珍娜，我们还收到了 CKFresh522 的评论，他写道，在你的视频博客中，在 3 分 10 秒处有 RC 跳进水里的镜头。
during your video blog at three minutes and 10 seconds. Oh my gosh, in the background. Yes, your whole video journal of our time on the Booze Cruise. That's right. Well, everyone, we hope you enjoyed these tidbits. Now, please enjoy time on the Booze Cruise. That's right. Well, everyone, we hope you enjoyed these tidbits. Now, please enjoy our breakdown of Booze Cruise. I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey.
哦天哪，在背景里。是的，你关于我们在《酒船之旅》拍摄期间的整个视频日记。没错。好吧，各位，希望你们喜欢这些花絮。现在，请享受我们在《酒船之旅》中的时光。没错。好吧，各位，希望你们喜欢这些花絮。现在，请享受我们对《酒船之旅》的拆解。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。
We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. We're gonna booze it up today. It is the Booze Cruise episode, everybody.
我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会拆解一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。我们今天要在《酒船之旅》里喝个痛快。各位，这就是《酒船之旅》那一集。
Are you running a party? Written by Greg Daniels, directed by Ken Quapus, Angela's been on a booze cruise. In the Cayman Islands. Ooh, I've been on a booze cruise of Lake Ozark, Missouri. That's the one I wanna go on. Oh yeah, live band, all of it, very similar. Okay, let's get into this.
你在办派对吗？由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，肯·夸普斯导演，安吉拉参加过酒船之旅。在开曼群岛。哦，我参加过密苏里州欧扎克湖的酒船之旅。那才是我想要去的。哦耶，现场乐队，应有尽有，非常相似。好了，让我们进入正题吧。
Let's get into it. I will start with a summary. I feel like this episode doesn't need it, but I'm gonna give one anyway. Michael takes the office on a booze cruise of Lake Wallinpah Pack. So corporate won't pay for any more parties, but Michael found a loophole. As long as he calls it a leadership training exercise, then corporate will endorse it.
让我们开始吧。我先做一个总结。我觉得这一集不需要总结，但我还是要给出一个。迈克尔带着办公室员工去瓦林帕帕克湖进行酒船之旅。公司不再为任何派对买单，但迈克尔找到了一个漏洞。只要他称之为领导力培训练习，公司就会支持。
So that's what he does, but it's really just an excuse for a party. Michael loves a party. All right, let's jump in with fast fact number one. Boo's Cruise was the first episode to air on Thursday nights. Yeah, this was a huge deal. This was a huge deal for us. Must-see TV lineup. We were so giddy about this. We were so excited.
所以他就是这么做的，但这其实只是派对的借口。迈克尔热爱派对。好了，让我们从第一个快速事实开始。《酒船之旅》是第一集在周四晚上播出的剧集。是的，这是一件大事。这对我们来说是一件大事。必看电视节目阵容。我们对此感到非常兴奋。我们太激动了。
I wrote a whole MySpace blog about it. I was so happy. I did too. Yeah. Announcing our move to Thursday nights because I don't know if people know, but we started on Tuesday nights at 930 and now we were moving to the Thursday must-see TV lineup. This was a coveted time slot, you guys. It's where Friends was. It was a big, big deal. It still is. It's still their big night of comedy. So we felt like we'd really made it.
我为此写了一整篇 MySpace 博客。我太开心了。我也写了。是的。宣布我们搬到周四晚上，因为我不知道人们是否知道，但我们最初是在周二晚上 9:30 播出，现在我们要搬到周四的“必看电视”阵容了。这是一个令人垂涎的时段，伙计们。那是《老友记》播出的时间。这可是件大事。现在依然如此。这仍然是他们重要的喜剧之夜。所以我们觉得我们真的成功了。
And also, this is a fan question from Sean Anna Yaa. In episode two of the podcast, Angela mentioned that she and the other supporting cast members became series regulars during the booze cruise. Yes! Angela, how did that feel? It was such an exciting time, Jenna, because our agents called us and said,
另外，这是一个来自 Sean Anna Yaa 的粉丝提问。在播客的第二集中，安吉拉提到她和其他配角在《酒船之旅》期间成为了剧组常驻演员。是的！安吉拉，那感觉如何？那是一个非常令人兴奋的时刻，珍娜，因为我们的经纪人打电话给我们说，
hey, they want to make you series regulars. We were all so, so excited. It also meant that maybe we wouldn't get fired. Now, did that happen in the middle of filming Boos Cruise or at the beginning? What was the timing? In the middle. We were on the boat. I remember we were on the boat when I got the call
嘿，他们想让你们成为剧组常驻演员。我们都非常、非常兴奋。这也意味着也许我们不会被解雇。那么，那是发生在拍摄《酒船之旅》的过程中还是开始时？时间点是什么时候？在中间。我们在船上。我记得当我们接到电话时，我们就在船上。
saying that NBC would like for you to be series regulars and you're going to have like an extended contract. You're not going to be a week to week day player. Oh my gosh. We were all talking. We were all so excited, the supporting cast. You and I, we had a break where we got to go off the boat, but we're standing right by the boat, Jenna.
说 NBC 希望你们成为剧组常驻演员，你们将获得一份延长的合同。你们不再是按周结算的临时演员了。哦天哪。我们都在谈论。我们都非常兴奋，配角们。你和我，我们有一个休息时间，可以离开船，但我们当时就站在船边，珍娜。
We're right by the boat. And I gave Oscar Nunez my camera and I said, Oscar, I want you to capture this moment. You and I had been jumping up and down, holding hands, screaming, cause we were so excited. And you have that photo? I have the photo and you and I had been jumping up and down, holding hands, screaming, because we were so excited. And you have that photo? I have the photo. And you and I look insane.
我们就在船边。我把我的相机给了奥斯卡·努涅斯，我说，奥斯卡，我想让你捕捉这一刻。你和我一直在跳上跳下，手拉着手，尖叫着，因为我们太兴奋了。你有那张照片吗？我有那张照片，你和我一直在跳上跳下，手拉着手，尖叫着，因为我们太兴奋了。你有那张照片吗？我有那张照片。而且你和我看起来疯疯癫癫的。
Because I'm sure we're so tired. We're tired, and we're mid jumping up in air holding hands, like two school girls. And Oscar was like, oh, you two are so silly. And he gave us a big hug. But this was job security. Yeah, and this, yes, this was like we all knew now, one, our show must be doing well because now they're going to pay us all to be here all the time. Yeah. And, and then we knew we had
因为我敢肯定我们太累了。我们很累，而且我们正跳在半空中手拉着手，像两个女学生。奥斯卡说，哦，你们两个太傻了。他给了我们一个大大的拥抱。但这可是工作保障。是的，而且这，是的，这就像我们现在都知道了，第一，我们的节目一定做得很好，因为现在他们要付钱让我们一直待在这里。是的。然后我们知道我们有
a job. Special, special. I know. Things are starting to turn now. We've been talking about how we were really wondering week to week if we had jobs and now we're starting to feel like, oh, we're on a TV show that's going to keep coming back. Now we still haven't been picked up for season three yet, but we know, okay, we at least have a job for like another 13 weeks at this point. This was the most job security any of us had had since the beginning of the show. Oh yeah, for sure, for sure.
一份工作。特别，特别。我知道。事情现在开始好转了。我们一直在谈论我们是如何每周都在担心是否还有工作，而现在我们开始觉得，哦，我们正在参加一个会持续播出的电视节目。现在我们还没有获得第三季的续订，但我们知道，好吧，至少我们现在还有大约 13 周的工作。这是自节目开始以来我们所有人拥有的最有保障的工作。哦是的，肯定的，肯定的。
All right, fast fact number two, let's talk about our guest stars. Big, big guest stars. First up, this is the third and final appearance of Amy Adams as Katie. Now I went back and I was looking at the timeline. She had not yet been nominated for her Academy Award for Junebug.
好了，第二个快速事实，让我们谈谈我们的客串明星。非常、非常大的客串明星。首先，这是艾米·亚当斯作为凯蒂的第三次也是最后一次露面。现在我回过头来看了看时间线。她当时还没有因为《甲虫》获得奥斯卡提名。
That happened just a couple weeks after we finished filming this episode, but there was a ton of buzz. There was a lot of buzz that she was gonna be an Oscar contender. And it was just so wonderful knowing her the way we did at this point and knowing that she had just been a hard working actress.
那发生在我们完成这一集拍摄后的几周，但当时有很多传闻。有很多传闻说她将成为奥斯卡竞争者。在这一点上，以我们了解她的方式，知道她一直是一个努力工作的女演员，这真是太美妙了。
Some things had gone her way, some things hadn't and to just sort of see this electricity around her and she is just such a humble, sweet, kind person. You just can't help but root for her. And I remember being so happy for her and hopeful. I was seated next to her for pretty much most of the work in this episode. And we just became such good friends doing this.
有些事情如她所愿，有些则不然，看到她周围的这种活力，而她又是一个如此谦逊、甜美、善良的人。你忍不住会为她加油。我记得我为她感到非常高兴，也充满希望。在这一集的大部分工作中，我都坐在她旁边。我们通过这次合作成为了非常好的朋友。
We shared so much about our lives and our hopes and our dreams, and she was just a very open, warm, generous person. And then, you know, this boat was no frills. No frills. No frills on this boat, okay? We were just sleeping on those benches between takes and she was all in. Another big guest star from this episode is Rob Riggle as Captain Jack.
我们分享了很多关于我们的生活、希望和梦想的事情，她是一个非常开放、温暖、慷慨的人。然后，你知道，这艘船没有任何多余的装饰。没有装饰。这艘船上没有装饰，好吗？我们在拍摄间隙只是睡在那些长椅上，她完全投入了。这一集的另一位大牌客串明星是饰演杰克船长的罗伯·里格尔。
Riggs! All right. So a few facts about Rob in case people don't know. He is a real Marine Corps veteran. He joined the Marines in 1990 with the intention of becoming a naval aviator, but then he left to pursue comedy. Yeah. Comedy.
里格斯！好的。所以关于罗伯的一些事实，以防人们不知道。他是一名真正的海军陆战队退伍军人。他于 1990 年加入海军陆战队，打算成为一名海军飞行员，但后来他离开去追求喜剧事业。是的。喜剧。
Yeah. But he stayed a member of the Marine Corps Reserves until he retired in 2013 after 23 years of service. I mean, he's the real deal. He is the real deal and the man has such a heart for service. You do the softball game with him. I do. He's one of the people.
是的。但他一直担任海军陆战队预备役成员，直到 2013 年服役 23 年后退役。我的意思是，他是真材实料。他是真材实料，而且这个人有一颗服务的心。你和他一起参加过垒球比赛。我参加过。他是为儿童慈善医院服务的人之一，罗伯对我来说就是一个灵感来源。嗯，你们可能还会从《周六夜现场》或《每日秀》中认出他，他在那里担任军事记者，或者从无数电影中认出他，包括和安吉拉·金赛一起出演的《毛茸茸的复仇》。他出演了《毛茸茸的复仇》，然后你可能不会从他和我一起拍的一个试播集里认出他，
He's one of the people for Children's Mercy Hospital and Rob is just an inspiration to me. Well, you guys out there might recognize him also from SNL or from The Daily Show where he played their military correspondent or from like a gazillion movies, including Furry Vengeance with Angela Kinsey. He was in Furry Vengeance and then you won't recognize him from a pilot he and I
那个试播集叫《加布里埃尔一家》，在福克斯电视台播出，但从未见天日，我们在里面扮演夫妻。我们玩得很开心。我一直告诉他，我说，罗伯，总有一天我们会再次扮演夫妻的。哦，我很想看到那个。你们会很棒的。是的，所以你认识他，你是他的朋友。
did called The Gabriels on Fox that Never Saw the Light of Day where we played husband and wife. We had so much fun. I keep telling him, I'm like, Rob someday we're gonna get to play husband and wife again. Oh, I would love to see that. You guys would be great. Yeah, so you know him, you're friends with him.
是的，我们是好朋友。所以我昨天给他打了电话，他真是个大忙人。我说，罗伯，你在哪？你在洛杉矶吗？因为我上次和他谈话时，他在苏格兰。哦。他好像在做一些非常有趣的事情。
Yes, we are pals. So I called him yesterday and he's like the busiest guy ever. I was like, Rob, where are you? Are you in Los Angeles? Because the last time I talked to him, he was in Scotland. Oh. He's like doing some really fun stuff.
但我和他谈过了，我说，罗伯，你对杰克船长和整个《酒船之旅》那一集有什么记忆？这是他说的。好的。他说，嗯，安，从个人层面来说，这是我离开《周六夜现场》后的第一份工作之一。
But I talked to him and I was like, Rob, what do you remember about Captain Jack and the whole Booze Cruise episode? And this is what he said. Okay. He said, well, Anne, on a personal level, it was one of the first jobs I had after leaving Saturday Night Live.
我当时非常紧张。我真的很菜，在镜头前没做过太多事情。我很害怕，我想做好工作，因为我太喜欢这个节目了。而且这个角色非常有趣。他还说他真的很喜欢我们在水上拍摄，而且是夜间拍摄。
I was so nervous. I was really green and I hadn't done much in front of a camera. I was scared and I wanted to do a good job because I loved the show so much. And the character was so much fun. He also said he really enjoyed that we shot on the water and that it was a night shoot.
他说，你知道，安，我不知道你是否还记得，但没有人能退回到他们的拖车里。在场景之间，你无处可去。所以我们整晚都待在那艘船上。我们坐在小隔间里闲逛，人们会在场景之间换座位。你会看到有人说，哦，让我们去和
And he said, you know, Anne, I don't know if you remember this, but no one could retreat to their trailers. Between scenes, you had nowhere to go. So we all hung out in that boat all night. We sat in the booths and hung out and people would sort of booth hop between scenes. You would have people that were like, oh, let's go talk
约翰、珍娜、艾米·亚当斯和大卫·丹曼谈谈。哦，让我们去和会计谈谈。你知道，所以他说这太有趣了。我们会换座位，每个人都会聚在一起。我觉得那天晚上我真的认识了一些人。他说的第二件事是，他为史蒂夫感到非常难过，因为史蒂夫整天都在拍摄《冒牌天神》。然后他会来到我们的片场，整晚都在拍摄。
to John and Jenna and Amy Adams and David Denman. Oh, let's go talk to the counting. You know, and so he said it was so fun. We would booth hop and everyone would hang out. And I really felt like I got to know some people that night. The second thing he said was he felt really bad for Steve because Steve was shooting Evan Almighty all throughout the day. And then he would come over to our set and film throughout the night.
但尽管史蒂夫很累，他依然善良、体贴且专业。他说史蒂夫真的成为了他职业道德的灵感来源。现在，如果你了解罗伯，你就知道他有惊人的职业道德，但他真的在史蒂夫身上看到了这一点。好的。所以他说的第三件事，他说，安吉，这会困扰我。它困扰了我 14 年。什么？他说，我必须说“瓦林帕帕克湖”。他说，安吉，这会困扰我。它困扰了我 14 年。什么？他说，我必须说“瓦林帕帕克湖”。他说，安吉，你刚才听到我怎么说的吗？瓦林帕帕克湖。
But even though Steve was so tired, he was still kind and thoughtful and professional. And he said that Steve really became an inspiration for him for work ethic. Now, if you know Rob, you know he has an amazing work ethic, but he really saw that in Steve. Okay. So the third thing he said, and he was like, Ange, this is going to haunt me. It's haunted me for 14 years. What? He said, I had to say Lake Wall and Paw Pack. And he said, Ange, this is going to haunt me. It's haunted me for 14 years. What? He said, I had to say Lake Wallenpah Pack. And he said, Ange, did you just hear how I said that? Lake Wallenpah Pack.
我说得就像它脱口而出一样，就像我在那里长大的一样。是的。他说，我就是说不出来。他说，我甚至不知道他们是否有一个可用的镜头。他说，我一定连续搞砸了 10 次。他说，我开始出汗了。我太尴尬了。
I said it like it just rolled off my tongue, like I grew up there. Yeah. He said, I could not get it. He said, I don't even know if they had a usable take. He said, I must have messed it up 10 times in a row. He said, I started sweating. I was so embarrassed.
哦，不。他说，我连续搞砸了 10 次。他说，我开始出汗了。我太尴尬了。哦，不。他说，我无法说出“瓦林帕帕克湖”。他说当他的拍摄结束，他开车回家时，他在从长滩回家的路上所做的一切，那是一个半小时的车程，他一直在说，瓦林帕帕克湖，瓦林帕帕克湖，瓦林帕帕克湖。他说，我在开车回家的车里可以毫无问题地说出来。他说，但我在拍摄时就是说不出来。他说，这困扰了我 14 年。
Oh, no. He said, I could not messed it up 10 times in a row. He said, I started sweating. I was so embarrassed. Oh no. He said, I could not say Wall and Paw Pack. He said when his shoot was done and he was driving home, all he did on his drive home from Long Beach, it was like an hour and a half drive, he was like, Lake Wall and Paw Pack, Wall and Paw Pack, Wall and Paw Pack. He said, I could say it with no problem in my car driving home. He said, but I could not say it in the take. And he said, and it's haunted me for 14 years.
罗伯，我爱你。我知道。罗伯太棒了，我崇拜他。非常感谢，罗伯。哦，那太神奇了。好情报，安吉。所以我们这一集还有另一位客串明星。布伦达·威瑟斯饰演布伦达，公司联络员，
Rob, I love you. I know. Rob is fantastic and I adore him. Thanks so much, Rob. Oh, that was amazing. Good intel, Ange. So we have yet another guest star on this episode. Brenda Withers plays Brenda, the corporate liaison
被派到酒船上监视迈克尔。关于布伦达有一些有趣的事实。让我们听听。布伦达和明迪·卡灵在《办公室》之前是一个写作团队。她们编写并出演了一部名为《马特和本》的外百老汇戏剧，讲述了马特·达蒙和本·阿弗莱克的友谊。她们扮演了马特和本。是的。
sent on the booze crews to keep tabs on Michael. And there's some fun facts about Brenda. Let's hear them. Brenda and Mindy Kaling were a writing team before The Office. They wrote and performed in an off-Broadway play called Matt and Ben, which was about the friendship of Matt Damon and Ben Affleck. And they played Matt and Ben. Yes.
布伦达扮演马特，明迪扮演本。故事背景设定在 1995 年，讲述了马特和本在成名之前在公寓里幻想成名的故事。这是一个巨大的成功。这是一个评论界的轰动之作。我真希望我能看到那个。我查了《纽约时报》的评论，评价非常高。
Brenda played Matt and Mindy played Ben. It was set in 1995 and it tells the story of Matt and Ben before they were stars in their apartment fantasizing about being famous. It was a huge hit. It was a smash critical hit. I would have loved to have seen that. I looked up the New York Times review and it was just glowing.
这确实让她们声名鹊起。这绝对是让明迪受到关注的原因。我们甚至还没谈到今天谁要来节目。我知道，我正要脱口而出，好像我们已经宣布了一样。我知道，我也想到了。我说，等等，我们甚至没提到今天谁要来节目。我知道，我正要脱口而出，好像我们已经宣布了一样。我知道，我也想到了，我说，等等，我们甚至没说，伙计们，
And this really put them on the map. And it's definitely what got Mindy noticed. We haven't even talked about this. We haven't even mentioned who's coming on the show today. I know, I was just about to let it roll off my tongue as if we had announced it. I know, I thought about it too. And I was like, wait, we didn't even mentioned who's coming on the show today. I know, I was just about to let it roll off my tongue as if we had announced it. I know, I thought about it too and I was like, wait, we didn't even say, you guys,
我们今天有一位超级巨大、超棒、客串中的客串嘉宾。格雷格·丹尼尔斯，该剧的创作者，今天将参加这一集。他随时都会到。他会和我们坐在一起。你可以看出我们有点兴奋。我们超级兴奋。他随时都会到。他会和我们坐在一起。你可以看出我们有点兴奋。
we have an amazingly huge, awesome, the guest of all guests is on today. Greg Daniels, the creator of the show, is coming on the episode today. He's gonna be here any minute. He is gonna sit with us. We are a little giddy, as you can tell. We're super giddy. He's going to be here any minute. He is going to sit with us. We are a little giddy, as you can tell.
我们超级兴奋。我相信他去看了那场演出，这就是他发现明迪的方式。是的，我们得问问他。我们会问他的。我们会问他的，因为他会在这里。因为他会在这里。是的，没错。格雷格·丹尼尔斯，《办公室》的剧集主管和这一集的编剧将加入我们。
We're super giddy. And I believe he went and saw this show and that's how he discovered Mindy. Yeah, we'll have to ask him. We'll ask him. We'll ask him because he'll be here. Because he's going to be here. Yes, that's right. Greg Daniels, showrunner of The Office and writer of this episode will be joining us.
这太搞笑了。为什么我们没有先说这个？谈谈埋没重点。我想我们只是太兴奋了。我知道我在看时钟，因为他很快就会到这里。所以我说，哦，让我们快点完成快速事实。因为格雷格很快就会到这里。
That's hilarious. Why did we not lead with that? Talk about burying the lead. I think we're just so excited. I know I'm watching the clock cause he's gonna be here soon. So I was like, oh, let's get fast facts done. Cause then Greg's gonna be here.
哦，只是快速事实。嘿，现在。快点完成你的快速事实。我有一个很好的快速事实花絮给你。不，我在开玩笑。我在开玩笑。好了，让我们完成这些快速事实，这样格雷格就能进来了。
Oh, just get fast facts. Hey now. Hurry up and get your fast facts. I had a good tidbit for you fast facts. No, I'm kidding. I'm kidding. All right, well let's finish with these fast facts so that Greg can get in here.
快速事实之三。我们在外景拍摄，伙计们，在船上。在船上。在船上。这在长滩港外，距离洛杉矶以南约 45 分钟路程。我们在那里拍了三天。现在，有两天我们是在船停靠时拍摄的。然后有一个晚上我们在移动，因为我们在长滩，他们把我们安置在一家酒店，我当时有这些宏大的幻想，以为我们会聚在酒店里，或者开派对之类的。
Fast fact number three. We shot on location, guys, on a boat. On a boat. On a boat. This was outside of the Long Beach Harbor, which is about 45 minutes south of Los Angeles. We shot there for three days. Now, for two of the days, we filmed while the boat was docked. And then there was one night when we were moving, because we were in Long Beach and they put us up at a hotel, I had these grand fantasies that we were gonna be all hanging out back at the hotel and like kind of partying or something.
我不知道，我以前从来没有在外景拍摄过。我们甚至没见过酒店。我们整晚都在船上，然后我们会去酒店，也许睡几个小时，然后我们就直接回去了。我对酒店没有任何记忆。不，我确实带了扑克筹码，以为我们会聚在酒店里玩扑克，但那从未发生。我们实际上是从傍晚一直拍到第二天太阳升起。是的，我在日记里写道，我们从下午 2:30 开始拍摄，通常在凌晨 5 点左右收工。我写道，接下来的一周我整周都能感觉到那艘船的晃动。我会在杂货店排队时意识到自己在摇晃。哦天哪。
I don't know, I like have this idea. I'd never really been on location before. We never even saw the hotel. Literally we were on the boat all night and we would go to the hotel and maybe sleep a few hours and then we'd go right back. I have no memory of the hotel. No, I did bring poker chips thinking that we would hang out
这太强烈了，因为即使船不动，你仍然在水上。嗯，是的，我甚至认为停靠时更糟，因为那时它会做这种奇怪的“砰、砰、砰”的动作。当你移动时，它会更好。这就像一种向前的运动。但那种在码头上晃动了好几天。哦天哪。哦天哪，勾起了回忆。
at the hotel and play poker, but it never happened. We actually filmed from like late afternoon, overnight until the sun came up. Yes, I wrote in my journal that we filmed from 2.30 PM and usually wrapped around 5 AM. And I wrote, I felt the motion of that boat all week the next week. I would be in line at the grocery store and realize I was swaying. Oh my gosh.
我有一些这一集的精彩照片，因为我带了我的相机，我的老式相机。我已经提到过当我发现自己成为常驻演员时我们拍了一张照片，但我一直把它带在船上。所以我有很多，我一直在看我所有的办公室照片，我所有的纪念品，《酒船之旅》占了很大一部分照片。
It was intense because even when the boat wasn't moving, you're still on water. Well yeah, even I actually think it's worse when you're just docked, because then it's like doing this weird like a lump, lump, lump, lump, lump kind of thing. And when you're moving, it's better. It's like a forward motion. But that kind of rocking against the dock for days on it. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh, just bringing back memories.
我带了我的摄像机。那时我们在这艘船上没有 iPhone，但我有一个小摄像机，我拍摄了我们所有的幕后花絮。我记得这个。关于《酒船之旅》的纪录片，你可以在 YouTube 上找到。如果你在 YouTube 上搜索“Jenna Fisher Booze Cruise documentary”，它就会弹出来。这太神奇了。我采访了剧组成员。我问他们做了什么，这非常有趣，因为你看到我们上了船。戴夫·罗杰斯，我们的剪辑师，我给了他所有的素材，他剪辑了这个视频。
I have some fantastic photos from this episode, because I brought my camera, my old school camera. I already mentioned we got a photo when I found out I was series regular, but I had it on the boat with me the whole time. So I have so many, I was looking at all my office photos, all my memorabilia and Boo's Cruise is a huge chunk of photos.
你看到我们都上了船，我们说，耶，酒船之旅！然后第一天晚上我们说，耶，酒船之旅，我们还在，我们在做，我们在做。到了第三天晚上，没人跟我说话了。但你绝对能看到进展。我看了整个视频，它让我笑了。伙计，它直接把我带回去了。
I brought my camcorder. Back then we didn't have iPhones on this boat, but I had a little camcorder and I filmed all of us behind the scenes. I remember this. A documentary of Booze Cruise, which you can find on YouTube. If you go on YouTube and like Jenna Fisher Booze Cruise documentary, it'll pop up. It's amazing. I interviewed crew members. I asked them what they did, and it's very funny because you see us getting on the boat. Dave Rogers, our editor, I gave him all the footage and he put together this video.
我们看起来也像 12 岁。我们确实看起来……我当时想，哦伙计，时间在我的脸上留下了痕迹。哦不。我想，哇，我们看起来太年轻了。好吧，这就是我所有的内容了。我们应该去接格雷格，让他进来，拆解这一集吗？
You see us all getting on the boat and we're like, yeah, the Booze Crews! And then the first night we're like, yeah, Booze Crews, we're still, we're doing it, we're doing it. And by the third night, no one will speak to me. But you definitely see the progression. I watched the whole thing and it just made me smile. Man, it just brought me right back.
是的，因为我有一大堆笔记卡。你真的有。我真的有。安吉拉很早就到了，因为因为我有太多的笔记卡要摆放。她有太多的笔记卡，以至于我进来时很震惊。我说，这是什么？
We also look 12 years old. We do. We just look so... I was like, oh man, time has marched on across my face. Oh no. I was like, wow, we look so young. Well, that's all I've got. Should we go get Greg and bring him in here and break down this episode?
不过就是这样。好了，让我们开始吧。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道，你经常听到关于在一段关系中要注意的“危险信号”，但如果，如果我们改变这种关注点，开始列出我们在朋友和伴侣身上寻找的“绿色信号”呢？你知道，就像与其把它框定为“这是我要避免的”，
Yes, cause I have a ton of note cards. You really do. I really do. Angela guys got here early because Because I had so many note cards to lay out. She had so many note cards that she was like, I came in and I was shocked. I said, what is this?
不如说，“这是我想要奔向的”。好的。好吧，如果你不确定你的绿色信号清单是什么，治疗可以帮助你识别它们。而且你知道 BetterHelp 是完全在线的，让治疗变得负担得起且方便，为全球超过 500 万人提供服务。你可以访问一个拥有超过 30,000 名持证治疗师的多样化网络，他们拥有广泛的专业领域。你也可以随时更换治疗师，
Here it is though. All right, well, let's do it. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, you often hear about like the red flags to look for in a relationship, but what if, what if we like changed that focus and started making a list of the green flags that we were looking for in friends and partners? You know, like more like instead of framing it, here's what I'm avoiding.
无需额外费用。通过 BetterHelp 发现你的人际关系绿色信号。今天就访问 BetterHelp.com/officeladies，你的第一个月可享受 10% 的折扣。那是 Better Help. H-E-L-P 点 com 斜杠 office ladies。警告。我有一种感觉不到疼痛的病。你是超级英雄。
Be like, here's what I want to run toward. OK. Well, if you're not sure what your list of green flags is, therapy can help you identify them. And you know BetterHelp is fully online, making therapy affordable and convenient, serving over five million people worldwide. You can access a diverse network of more than 30,000 credentialed therapists with a wide range of specialties. You can also switch therapists at any time
这就是《诺娃·凯恩》听起来有多强烈……哦，哇！……想象一下它看起来是什么样。还有更多吗？是的，非常多。《诺娃·凯恩》。3 月 14 日仅在影院上映。有很多事情我想做和看。
at no extra cost. Discover your relationship green flags with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's Better Help. H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. Warning. I've got this condition where I don't feel pain. You're a superhero.
比如重做地下室而不必自己动手。或者什么都不做。当然，要有壮观的瀑布景观。所以我从这里开始，投资 RBC。当谈到实现你的目标时，个性化的建议和表现很重要。现在，当你投资 RBC 时，你可以获得 300 美元。优惠于 2025 年 3 月 3 日结束。
This is how intense Nova Kane sounds... Oh, wow! ...imagine how it looks. Is there more? Yeah, big time. Nova Kane. Only in theaters March 14th. There's so many things I want to do and see.
适用条款和条件。今天就投资 RBC。适用条款。今天就投资 RBC。好的伙计们，我们休息回来了，我们正和《酒船之旅》的编剧、《办公室》的剧集主管格雷格·丹尼尔斯坐在一起。格雷格，非常感谢你的到来。嗯，非常感谢你们邀请我。我喜欢你们的节目。你们在一起真是太棒了。听你们说话非常有趣，听到你们的声音、观点和一切对我来说都很有趣。非常感谢，格雷格。
Like redoing the basement without having to do it all myself. Or doing absolutely nothing. With a spectacular waterfall view, of course. So I'm starting here, investing with RBC. When it comes to reaching your goals, personalized advice and performance matter. And now you can get $300 when you invest with RBC. Offer ends March 3rd, 2025.
如果不是你，格雷格，我们就不会成为最好的朋友，这个节目也不会存在。我们的生活会完全，我甚至不知道。老实说，我甚至无法用语言表达，因为现在我会变得情绪化。我来了。
Terms and conditions apply. Invest with RBC today. conditions apply. Invest with RBC today. Okay guys, we're back from our break and we are sitting here with Greg Daniels, writer of Booze Cruise, showrunner of The Office. Greg, thank you so much for coming in. Well, thank you so much for inviting me. I love your show. You guys are so good together. It's so entertaining to hear you and it's so fun for me to hear your voices and your points of view and everything. Thank you so much, Greg.
安吉拉已经在哭了。我已经，我不能。抱歉。这只是让我感触良多。你知道吉姆怎么说他敢打赌迈克尔在这一集中会做泰坦尼克号的动作吗？是的。我会说安吉拉会流泪。而且已经发生了。
If not for you, Greg, we would not be best friends and this show wouldn't exist. Our lives would be completely, I don't even know. I can't even put it into words, honestly, because now I'll get emotional. Here I go.
发生得太快了。我知道。抱歉。我只是像海浪一样被我对你的感激之情淹没了，我心中绝对的感激。同样。是的，你。这对我们所有人来说都是一段美好的时光。
Angel's crying already. I'm already, I can't. Sorry. It just all kind of hit me. You know how Jim says he'll bet a paycheck that Michael in this episode is going to do the Titanic thing? Yeah. I would have said Angel was going to tear up. And it happened already.
如果你们的友谊是唯一从中产生的东西，那也会很酷。哦。然而事实并非如此，不是吗？我知道。不。嗯，格雷格，当我们有嘉宾时，我们总是喜欢先问他们，
It happened so soon. I know. I'm sorry. I just all like the wave hit me of just gratitude I have for you, just absolute gratitude in my heart. Likewise. Yeah, you. It was a great time for all of us.
他们是如何最终参加《办公室》的？你是如何最终为美国电视开发《办公室》的？我会回溯一点，因为在节目开始时，我的职业生涯已经有了一定基础。你有一个非常成功的职业生涯，格雷格。我的意思是，你做过《山丘之王》，我不会列出你的 IMDb，但你是真材实料。你有一个非常成功的职业生涯，格雷格。我的意思是，你做过《山丘之王》。我不会列出你的 IMDb，但你是真材实料。
And if your friendship was the only thing that came out of it, that would be cool. Oh. And yet it's not, is it? I know. No. Well, Greg, when we have guests, we always like to start with asking them,
请继续。人们对它了解不够。你创作了《山丘之王》。《山丘之王》。而且你在管理那个节目。是的，是的。但你曾在《周六夜现场》和《辛普森一家》写过剧本。
how did they end up being on the office? How did you end up developing the office for American television? I will go back a little ways because I was kind of already with a career at the time that the show started. You had a very successful career, Greg. I mean, you had done King, I won't list your IMDb, but you were the real deal. You had a very successful career, Greg. I mean, you had done King of the Hill. I won't list your IMDB, but you were the real deal.
《辛普森一家》永远。哦天哪，你在《辛普森一家》里写的那首歌真是太棒了。总之，好的，好的。谁需要 Quickie Mart？是的，谁需要，是的，是的。好的。所以你是真材实料。事情正在进行中。所以是的，所以我处于一个很好的位置。你知道他们怎么说你需要 10,000 小时才能在某件事上变得出色吗？是的。
Please, go ahead. People don't know it enough. You created King of the Hill. King of the Hill. And you were running that show. Yeah, yeah. But you had written on Saturday Night Live and- Simpsons.
所以我已经在《辛普森一家》和《周六夜现场》上花了大约 10,000 小时，然后在《山丘之王》上又花了大约 15,000 小时。所以我准备好了。发生的事情是我的经纪人寄给我《办公室》的录像带，它在这里相当不为人知，而且标题相当无聊，我没看。BBC 版本。BBC 版本，是的。所以他打电话给我，那是在圣诞节期间，在我们节目播出前两年。
The Simpsons forever. And oh my gosh, there's that one song that you wrote on the Simpsons that is just amazing. Anyway, okay, okay. Who Needs a Quickie Mart? Yes, who needs, yes, yes. Okay. So you were the real deal. Things were cooking. So yeah, so I was in a good position. You know how they say like you need 10,000 hours to be good at something? Yes.
他说，好吧，如果你不看，我就把它寄给别人了。我说，哦，好的，等等，等等，我今晚看。我在 11 点左右把它放进去，一直看到凌晨三点左右。我觉得它简直太棒了。所以我打电话说，我真的很想见见这些人。而且我在职业生涯中一直像个好学生，你知道。我总是想与我尊重的人互动。而且，你知道，我把剧集卖给了《宋飞正传》，这样我就可以和拉里·大卫一起工作。这对我的职业生涯来说是一个重要的举措。
So I had sort of 10,000 hours on The Simpsons and Saturday Night Live, and then I had another like 15,000 hours on King of the Hill. So I was like prepared. And what happened was my agent sent me the tape of the office and it was pretty unknown over here and it had a pretty boring title and I didn't watch it. The BBC version. The BBC version, yes. And so he called me, it was over Christmas, like two years before our show came out.
而且我认定瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫昌特所做的事情使他们跻身于从事这一行业的人的前列。所以我真的很想见他们。而且我真的不认为它可以被改编。所以我有点在骗他们。我说，我要去见你们
He said, all right, I'm going to send this to somebody else if you don't watch it. I was like, oh, okay, hang on, hang on, I'll watch it tonight. I put it in around 11 and I stayed up till like three in the morning watching it. I thought it was just brilliant. So I called and I said, I really want to meet these guys. And I had been kind of like a good little student, you know, always in my career. And I always wanted to interact with people who I respected. And, you know, I sold the episode to Seinfeld so I could work with Larry David. And that was like a career important move for me.
并参加这个有趣的会议。从你们那里获取知识。问你们问题。建立关系，也许是为了未来的事情。你永远不知道什么不会是这个。就像，我要去见你们并参加这个有趣的会议。从你们那里获取知识。是的，我知道。问你们问题。建立关系。也许是为了未来的事情。你永远不知道。什么会是这个？
And I kind of identified that Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant had done something that put them in the top ranks of people working in this profession. So I really wanted to meet them. And I didn't really think it could be adapted. So I was kind of scamming them. I was like, I'm gonna go meet you
总之，我们在本·西尔弗曼的办公室见面，因为他拥有版权，我们相处得很好，因为事实证明他们喜欢美国电视，特别是《辛普森一家》，特别是他们最喜欢的剧集，或者瑞奇最喜欢的剧集是《荷马坏人》，那是我写的，所以我们一拍即合。这太神奇了！我告诉他们，你知道，我关于制作电视节目的所有理论，我在《山丘之王》中付诸实践，那就是，你知道，更慢的节奏，允许尴尬和现实主义，以及所有这些东西。
and take this interesting meeting. Take your knowledge from you. Ask you questions. Build a relationship maybe for something in the future. You never know what's not gonna be this. It's like, I'm gonna go meet you and take this interesting meeting. Take your knowledge from you. Yeah, I know. Ask you questions. Build a relationship. Maybe for something in the future. You never know. What's gonna be this?
去参加这个有趣的会议，从你那里获取知识，向你提问，也许能为未来建立某种关系。你永远不知道会发生什么。就像，我要去见你，参加这个有趣的会议，从你那里获取知识。是的，我知道。向你提问，建立关系，也许是为了未来。你永远不知道会发生什么。
And anyway, so we met over at Ben Silverman's office because he had the rights and we got along very well because it turned out that they loved American TV and specifically The Simpsons and specifically their favorite episode or Ricky's favorite episode was Homer bad man which I had written and so we kind of hit it off. That's amazing! And I was telling them you know all the kind of theories that I had about making a TV show that I put into place in King of the Hill which was you know a slower pace and allowing for awkwardness and realism and all this stuff.
总之，我们在本·西尔弗曼的办公室见面，因为他拥有版权，我们相处得非常好，因为事实证明他们喜欢美国电视节目，特别是《辛普森一家》，尤其是他们最喜欢的一集，或者说瑞奇最喜欢的一集是《荷马是个坏男人》，那一集是我写的，所以我们一见如故。太棒了！我当时告诉他们我关于制作电视节目的所有理论，这些理论我后来应用到了《乡巴佬希尔》中，比如节奏更慢，允许尴尬和现实主义等等。
And they really responded to that. So we decided, well, maybe I would be the person to adapt it into America. And then there was a couple of months where we were kind of hammering it out. But it was always the thought was always to bring it to someplace cool and cabley, because the show was not like what was on TV. You know, I think the biggest show at the time was Will and Grace, which was very kind of multi-camera, fast-paced.
他们对此反应非常热烈。所以我们决定，也许我可以成为把它改编到美国的人。之后有几个月的时间，我们一直在敲定细节。但我们的初衷始终是把它带到一个很酷、有线电视风格的地方，因为这部剧和当时电视上的节目完全不同。你知道，我觉得当时最火的剧是《威尔和格蕾丝》，那是典型的多机位、快节奏风格。
Far more broad. Yeah, very different feel. Yeah, it didn't have a network feel of like television. Yeah, it felt weird. So we were talking about, well, maybe we'll go to HBO and apparently Kevin Reilly at FX really likes it. So we had a couple of thoughts. And anyway, so I signed on to do it. And then Kevin Reilly left FX and went to NBC. And HBO didn't want to do it because they
更大众化。是的，感觉非常不同。没错，它没有那种电视网节目的感觉。是的，感觉很怪。所以我们当时在讨论，也许我们可以去HBO，但显然FX的凯文·赖利真的很喜欢它。所以我们有几个想法。总之，我签了约。然后凯文·赖利离开了FX去了NBC。而HBO不想做，因为他们
didn't want to do a remake. And Ben was like, you got to sell this to NBC. And then I got very worried because I was like, this is not going to work on NBC. You're like, this isn't what I signed up for. Cool cable show. Yeah, exactly. And I also had these stress dreams
不想做翻拍。本当时说，你得把它卖给NBC。我当时非常担心，因为我觉得这在NBC行不通。你当时就像是说，这不是我签约时想要的那种酷酷的有线电视节目。是的，没错。而且我还会做压力梦，
where I would be put on trial by all the comedy nerds in the world for doing this lousy NBC version of The Office. But eventually we were like, well, maybe the value of it will be to move network comedy into a new direction, maybe open it up just a little bit and make it more like what I liked about animation, which was single camera and didn't have a laugh track and stuff like that. So I was like, okay, I kind of convinced myself it was worth doing just for that. And it ushered in this whole new type of American television. Completely. All right, well, let's get into Boo's Cruise. All right, let's do it, Jenna.
梦见我因为制作了这个糟糕的NBC版《办公室》而被全世界的喜剧极客审判。但最终我们想，也许它的价值在于将电视网喜剧推向一个新的方向，也许稍微开放一点，让它更像我喜欢的动画片风格，也就是单机位、没有罐头笑声等等。所以我当时想，好吧，我算是说服了自己，单凭这一点就值得去做。它开启了美国电视的一种全新类型。完全是这样。好了，让我们进入“酒水游轮”这一集吧。好的，开始吧，珍娜。
What was the inspiration for this episode? You know, one of the things we were doing was we were looking for classic office situations and trying to test them for was there comic potential. And the idea of going on a booze cruise sounded funny. And this was like our biggest episode yet. This was where we were kind of feeling some oats as a show. And if you remember, they bought a whole bunch of hotel rooms for everybody. And this was sort of gonna be like the new thing.
这一集的灵感是什么？你知道，我们当时做的一件事就是寻找经典的办公室情境，并试图测试它们是否具有喜剧潜力。去参加酒水游轮的想法听起来很有趣。这是我们当时最大的一集。这是我们作为一部剧开始感到自信的时候。如果你还记得，他们为每个人订了一大堆酒店房间。这算是当时的新鲜事。
We were maybe gonna have more location shooting and it was very exciting. Speaking of the booze cruise, when we were on the boat, I remember I was standing next to you and I had told you that I had been on a booze cruise and I had done a snorkel shot like when we were talking about them after the-
我们可能打算进行更多的外景拍摄，这非常令人兴奋。说到酒水游轮，当我们在船上时，我记得我站在你旁边，我告诉你我曾经参加过一次酒水游轮，还做过“浮潜射击”（snorkel shot），当时我们是在……之后谈论这些的。
Did we roll with that right away from that? No, no, no, we were, so I think we read, we had the table read, we read the script and I went up to you and I was like, this is great. I said, you know, I went on one of these and it is, it gets crazy. I mean, there were snorkel shots and you're like snorkel shots and you're like, okay, I want to talk to you more about snorkel shots. And then you kind of
我们当时马上就用了那个点子吗？不，不，不，我们当时……我想我们读了剧本，我们进行了剧本围读，我走到你面前说，这太棒了。我说，你知道吗，我参加过这种活动，真的很疯狂。我是说，有“浮潜射击”，你当时说“浮潜射击？”，然后你说，好吧，我想和你多聊聊浮潜射击。然后你……
went off and we were like, just like you were busy with the episode. It was a very big episode. And then we were on the boat and I think you had mentioned it to Phil Shea. And so he had snorkels and I just remember all of a sudden I was like talking to Brian and Oscar and I heard Angela, Angela, get over here. And it was you and you're like, get over here. Talk to them about snorkel shots. I was like, oh, okay. You poured it at the top. And so we sort of had this quick snorkel shot tutorial and then it made it in the episode.
走开了，我们当时就像……你当时正忙着拍这一集。这集规模很大。后来我们在船上，我想你向菲尔·谢提到了这件事。所以他准备了呼吸管，我只记得突然间我正在和布莱恩还有奥斯卡说话，我听到“安吉拉，安吉拉，过来这里”。是你，你说“过来这里，跟他们讲讲浮潜射击”。我说，哦，好的。你从顶部倒进去。所以我们算是进行了一个快速的浮潜射击教程，然后它就出现在剧集里了。
That's great. I forgot about that. It was just so fun. I always, we talk about this a lot, how you were so open to in the moment collaboration and getting people's ideas. And it made for such a fun, awesome work environment. Yes, completely. I loved that work that you guys did.
太棒了。我把那件事忘了。真的太有趣了。我总是……我们经常谈论这个，你当时是多么乐于进行即兴合作，采纳大家的想法。这创造了一个非常有趣、很棒的工作环境。是的，完全同意。我喜欢你们当时所做的工作。
Because part of the thing that I wanted to do with the show was the experiences that I'd had that I didn't like in show business were mostly factory-made TV, where they keep the writers over here and the actors are over here and nobody talks to each other and they got to get the scripts out fast and it didn't feel very creative and I really wanted to mix it all and have a more handmade feel to it and so I had a lot of the writers act and I would ask the some of the actors to write and I always love to get access to the kind of actor prepares
因为我想要通过这部剧实现的一部分目标是，我在演艺圈经历过那些我不喜欢的工厂化电视制作，他们把编剧放在这边，演员放在那边，谁也不跟谁说话，他们必须快速赶出剧本，这感觉一点也不具创造性。我真的想把这一切融合起来，让它有一种更手工制作的感觉，所以我让很多编剧去演戏，我也要求一些演员去写剧本，我一直很喜欢那种演员准备工作，
work that you guys did. You know, and, and I would hop on any great ad lib like that whole thing with rain being Amish just came out of an ad lib, if you remember, where he was talking about his grandfather's name and he said Dwight Schrude Amish. And then we were like, ooh. And then you just ran with it. Yeah, that sounded fun. I also remember in the casting process, we initially wanted Steve,
也就是你们所做的那种工作。你知道，我会抓住任何精彩的即兴发挥，比如雷恩扮演阿米什人的那整件事，就是即兴发挥出来的，如果你还记得的话，当时他在说他祖父的名字，他说“德怀特·施鲁特，阿米什人”。然后我们当时就想，噢。然后你就顺着那个思路演下去了。是的，那听起来很有趣。我还记得在选角过程中，我们最初想要史蒂夫，
and then he took that other show, Come to Papa before Alison Jones came on board. I don't know if you know that. No. Yeah, so we had heard, Ben had specifically heard about how cool, great Steve was in Bruce Almighty, and he really had that amazing sort of scene stealing moment where he's speaking in tongues as the newscaster.
然后他在艾莉森·琼斯加入之前接了另一部剧《Come to Papa》。我不知道你知不知道。不知道。是的，所以我们听说，本特别听说史蒂夫在《冒牌天神》里有多酷、多棒，他确实有那个令人惊叹的抢戏时刻，就是他作为新闻主播说方言的那一段。
Yes. And everybody knew he was really great and would be a good choice for this. And I'm very methodical, as you know, and I was like, okay, that sounds great. First, I wanna get the casting director on board and I really wanted to use Allison Jones from her works on Freaks and Geeks, which I loved.
是的。每个人都知道他真的很棒，会是这个角色的好人选。而且你知道，我做事很有条理，我当时想，好吧，听起来不错。首先，我想让选角导演加入，我真的很想用艾莉森·琼斯，因为她参与过《怪胎与书呆》，我很喜欢那部剧。
And it took two weeks to get her on board. And in those two weeks, Steve took this other show. And we were like, ah! You know, it might have been. I didn't know that. Yeah, it was awful. So then we went on this incredibly long process of looking at every single person in town
花了两个星期才让她加入。而在那两个星期里，史蒂夫接了另一部剧。我们当时就想，啊！你知道，可能就是那样。我不知道。是的，太糟糕了。所以我们经历了一个极其漫长的过程，观察了城里每一个
who could possibly be in the age range for Michael Scott. And including various writer friends that I had who I threw into the mix and just normal people, like we walk down the street, go, oh, you look good. You know, come in. Come in. Read this. Yeah, but anyway, it came full circle.
年龄段可能适合迈克尔·斯科特的人。包括我认识的各种编剧朋友，我都把他们加了进来，还有普通人，就像我们在街上走，说“哦，你看上去不错，你知道，进来，进来，读一下这个”。是的，但总之，兜兜转转又回到了原点。
And then after three months of intense casting, we got a little tip off from Kevin Reilly that maybe come to Papa wasn't gonna go the distance and we could get Steve in second position to that other show and we'd be safe and so. Let's get into Boo's Cruise. Oh my gosh. All right.
在经历了三个月紧张的选角后，我们从凯文·赖利那里得到了一点小道消息，说《Come to Papa》可能不会长久，我们可以让史蒂夫作为该剧的第二顺位人选，这样我们就安全了。好了，让我们进入“酒水游轮”吧。天哪。好的，开始吧。
No card, no card. Okay, okay. I'm saying no card. I'm saying cold open. No card. Oh wait, Greg has a no card. Greg has one, go. No card, minute 45.
没卡片，没卡片。好的，好的。我说没卡片。我说冷开场。没卡片。等等，格雷格有卡片。格雷格有一张，开始。没卡片，第45分钟。
Oh, yes, yes. An early one. I believe Kevin is packing a Speedo. A metallic blue Speedo. Yes. And lots of condoms. And condoms, yes. And lots of condoms.
哦，是的，是的。很早的一集。我相信凯文带了一条泳裤。一条金属蓝色的泳裤。是的。还有很多避孕套。还有避孕套，是的。还有很多避孕套。
Also, we have a great Jim Pam talking head, a joint talking head, which I know was really fun for you guys to do right before that. Yes, where we're reading the memo from Michael that he has sent around, telling us to prepare for a surprise outing. He tells us to pack a toothbrush, a swimsuit, a ski mask, and wear
另外，我们有一个很棒的吉姆和帕姆的访谈，一个联合访谈，我知道这对你们来说在那个场景之前做起来真的很有趣。是的，我们正在读迈克尔发出的备忘录，告诉我们要为一次惊喜郊游做准备。他告诉我们要带牙刷、泳衣、滑雪面罩，还要穿上
your rubber-soled shoes. I love how delighted Pam is by Jim and this talking head. And also at 1 minute 53 seconds, please notice the winter Scranton backdrop outside of the window of our talking head. We would change those backdrops seasonally. They were, we had a springtime one. We had a summer and a winter. So this was our winter backdrop out the window. January on Lake Wallenpop. That's right.
你的橡胶底鞋。我喜欢帕姆对吉姆和这个访谈表现出的那种高兴劲儿。还有在1分53秒，请注意我们访谈窗外斯克兰顿的冬季背景。我们会根据季节更换那些背景。我们有一个春季的，还有一个夏季和冬季的。所以这就是我们窗外的冬季背景。一月在瓦伦帕克湖。没错。
Stanley's like a booze cruise in January. And also on that note, like we said, we are jumping ahead, but at six minutes, 45 seconds, when Kevin is walking down the ramp to get on the boat, he is wearing a ski mask. Is he? You see a man in a ski mask. Oh, Jina, you're right.
斯坦利说“一月去酒水游轮？”。还有，就像我们说的，我们跳得有点远，但在6分45秒，当凯文走下坡道上船时，他戴着滑雪面罩。是吗？你看到一个戴着滑雪面罩的人。哦，珍娜，你是对的。
That's such a good catch. He followed the memo to a T. Wait. OK, wait. Now, wait. We do have to give our background people who love the background stuff. In the cold open, what all is in the vending machine? Oh, yes. wait, now wait, we do have to give our background people who love the background stuff in the cold open, what all is in the vending machine?
这真是个好发现。他完全照着备忘录做了。等等。好的，等等。我们必须给那些喜欢背景细节的观众交代一下。在冷开场里，自动售货机里都有什么？哦，是的，等等，我们必须给那些喜欢背景细节的观众交代一下，在冷开场里，自动售货机里都有什么？
Oh yes, oh yes, the cold open, Jim puts Dwight's stuff in the vending machine. Pam buys Dwight's pencil cup. Which is letter H is the pencil, metal pencil cup. Someone did a deep dive. G is Dwight's desk name plate. FF is a picture frame of Reign's actual family. Yes, fan question. Hannah Watkins asked, there is a framed picture in the vending machine. Is that a real photo from Reign's childhood? It is a photo of Reign's aunt and uncle and
哦是的，哦是的，冷开场，吉姆把德怀特的东西放进了自动售货机。帕姆买了德怀特的笔筒。字母H是那个金属笔筒。有人做了深度挖掘。G是德怀特的办公桌名牌。FF是雷恩现实中家人的相框。是的，粉丝提问。汉娜·沃特金斯问，自动售货机里有一张装在框里的照片。那是雷恩童年的真实照片吗？那是雷恩的姑姑、叔叔和
nephew. Mm-hmm. Yes. Reign had brought in, I remember, a family photo album of sort of country cousins of his that lived in Oregon, I think. And that was part of what he was drawing from for Dwight. For his character, yes. Yeah, and I think we put it in a frame. Yes.
侄子的照片。嗯。是的。我记得雷恩带了一本家庭相册，里面是他住在俄勒冈州的乡下表亲，我想。那也是他塑造德怀特时借鉴的一部分。为了他的角色，是的。是的，我想我们把它放进了一个相框里。是的。
Oh, that's perfect. It's so good. HH was a stapler. I was Mike, Greg, I might say this wrong, Mike Leberthal. He was a bobblehead of a Phillies baseball coach. I don't know. I don't know the Phillies. Well, that's something that you shouldn't really
哦，那太完美了。太棒了。HH是一个订书机。我是迈克……格雷格，我可能说错了，迈克·利伯塔尔。他是一个费城人队棒球教练的摇头娃娃。我不知道。我不了解费城人队。好吧，那确实不是你应该
go to me for. I'll tell you that right now. There was, I mean, Phil Shea, who was a brilliant prop master on our show for the whole time of the show, used to go to Scranton and return with truckloads of tchotchkes from the different businesses and giveaway pens and local sports figure bobbleheads and stuff.
问我的事。我现在就可以告诉你。当时，我是说，菲尔·谢，他是我们剧组全程的杰出道具师，他过去常去斯克兰顿，带回一卡车的各种小玩意儿，有来自不同企业的赠品笔、当地体育明星的摇头娃娃之类的东西。
And I think that was on the Penguins maybe. No, he was a Phillies. He's a Phillies? I looked him up. I Googled him. Mike Lieberthal, he was a Philadelphia Phillies catcher on their baseball team. And then also letter J is Dwight's wallet.
我想那个可能是企鹅队的吧。不，他是费城人队的。他是费城人队的？我查过他。我谷歌了他。迈克·利伯塔尔，他是费城费城人队的一名捕手。然后字母J是德怀特的钱包。
Yes. And Jim gives Dwight a bag of nickels to get all his stuff back, which I love that detail. So then we go to the scene where Stanley goes into Michael's office to find out if they will be spending the night. And Michael is so coy and just loves that nobody knows where they're going. And Stanley says, should my wife tell her boss she's not coming in tomorrow? And he's like Stanley, Bo Manley, Banana Nana Family, me, my mom, and Lee Stanley. Like he can't, poor Stanley can't get anything out because Michael's interrupting him with
是的。吉姆给了德怀特一袋镍币让他拿回所有东西，我喜欢这个细节。然后我们进入斯坦利走进迈克尔办公室询问他们是否会过夜的场景。迈克尔非常装模作样，他就是喜欢没人知道他们要去哪儿。斯坦利说：“我妻子该告诉她老板她明天不去上班了吗？”然后他说：“斯坦利，波曼利，香蕉娜娜家庭，我，我妈妈，还有李·斯坦利。”他根本……可怜的斯坦利什么也问不出来，因为迈克尔一直在用
this ridiculous like song. That was also like an early season running joke was him changing people's names. He did it to Pam constantly. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. It feels like we dropped that after a few years. Yeah. He didn't really do that to people anymore.
这种荒谬的歌打断他。这也是早期剧集的一个惯用笑话，就是他乱改别人的名字。他经常对帕姆这么做。哦，是的。哦，是的。感觉几年后我们就放弃这个梗了。是的。他后来真的不再那样对别人了。
All right. We move into the conference room where Michael finally reveals to everyone that they're going on a booze cruise of Lake Wallenpah Pack. I became obsessed with the question personally, do they really have booze cruises of Lake Wall and Paw Pack? Yes and no. I did a deep dive on the internet. So what they mostly have are pontoon boat tours, open-air tours where a guide tells you about the scenery. Well that boat, the real boat that we filmed on was a boat from Long Beach Harbor and was big metal boat.
好了。我们进入会议室，迈克尔终于向大家透露他们要去瓦伦帕克湖参加酒水游轮。我个人对这个问题变得很着迷，他们真的有瓦伦帕克湖的酒水游轮吗？既是也不是。我在网上做了深度挖掘。他们主要有的是浮筒船游览，那种露天游览，导游会向你介绍风景。嗯，那艘船，我们拍摄时用的那艘真正的船，是一艘来自长滩港的船，是一艘巨大的金属船。
I can't picture how it would have gotten to Lake Wallenpah Pack, which is, you know. Yes, also, I did a little bit of a deep dive. I think they have like a motor restriction law. On Lake Wallenpah Pack? Yeah. So like you can only have like, I don't think our boat size would be permitted. Well, supposedly they do have a dinner cruise. So if you're in the area, you can look that up.
我无法想象它怎么会到瓦伦帕克湖，你知道的。是的，而且，我也做了一点深度挖掘。我想他们有某种马力限制法。在瓦伦帕克湖？是的。所以你只能有……我不认为我们那艘船的大小是被允许的。好吧，据说他们确实有晚餐游轮。所以如果你在那个地区，你可以查一下。
I'm sure there's beer and wine. I mean, I'm not sure, but. Wait, can we, okay, in the conference room scene, first of all, these are some of my favorite scenes because Michael has something he so desperately is trying to say, and then we just keep interrupting him. I went and looked at the first draft of the episode, and there is a scene that was in the first draft
我相信有啤酒和葡萄酒。我是说，我不确定，但是。等等，我们可以……好的，在会议室场景里，首先，这些是我最喜欢的场景之一，因为迈克尔有他非常迫切想要说的话，然后我们一直打断他。我去看了这一集的第一稿，第一稿里有一个场景，
where Brenda, the person from corporate, tells Michael that she hears he's planning this booze cruise and she tells him that corporate won't pay for it unless it has a certain amount of educational content. he's planning this booze cruise and she tells him that corporate won't pay for it unless it has a certain amount of educational content. And he panics because he hadn't prepared anything. And then we go into the conference room scene and he's trying to make up stuff off the top of his head. Leadership. It's all about the pause. But we had a very hard time keeping a straight
布伦达，那个来自总公司的人，告诉迈克尔她听说他在策划这个酒水游轮，她告诉他，除非有一定程度的教育内容，否则总公司不会买单。他很恐慌，因为他什么都没准备。然后我们进入会议室场景，他试图临时编造一些东西。领导力。关键在于停顿。但我们在那个场景里很难保持
face in the scene as we often did in conference room scenes. And I caught a few people breaking. Mindy? Mindy at three minutes, 41 seconds. When she says I took the tags off already, when she's talking about her bathing suit, because Michael says bring a bathing suit, and now she doesn't need one,
严肃的表情，就像我们在会议室场景里经常做的那样。我抓到几个人笑场了。敏迪？敏迪在3分41秒。当她说“我已经把标签撕掉了”时，当她在谈论她的泳衣时，因为迈克尔说带上泳衣，现在她不需要了，
Mindy puts her hand to her mouth. Yeah, she covers her mouth. And that's what she would do when she was about to break. Mindy was an easy breaker, that's for sure. So easy. Her hair is half up, half down, Kelly. We're tracking when Kelly is fully Mindy. Because Greg, maybe you can shine some light on this.
敏迪把手捂在嘴上。是的，她捂住了嘴。这就是她快要笑场时会做的动作。敏迪确实很容易笑场。太容易了。她的头发一半扎起，一半放下，凯莉。我们正在追踪凯莉什么时候完全变成了敏迪。因为格雷格，也许你能解释一下。
Mindy, the character of Kelly Kapoor started out as a very kind of like stuffy, updo. Her hair was in a bun. She always had. She had like a paisley top on. That went all the way up to her neck. Like an ascot kind of thingy. Yes, and then she very slowly just turns into Mindy Kaling.
敏迪，凯莉·卡普尔这个角色最初是一种非常……那种死板的盘发。她的头发扎成发髻。她总是……她穿了一件佩斯利花纹的上衣。一直高到脖子。像那种领巾一样的东西。是的，然后她非常缓慢地变成了敏迪·卡灵。
Yes. Basically, and now her hair has transitioned. Well, this is a long campaign that Mindy waged. Behind the scenes, taking, you know, and I know she plotted it and every step was a victory and a lot of it would be we'd kind of do a double take and go, hey wait, what what are you wearing? And she would have, she would have slipped something in. Yeah, and she kind of hijacked that character and made it into her character. Well, we are enjoying watching the slow evolution of this. It's been really fun. Yes. I think her hair has now transformed. We're waiting for her wardrobe to transform.
是的。基本上，现在她的头发已经转变了。好吧，这是敏迪发起的一场长期运动。在幕后，你知道，我知道她是策划好的，每一步都是一次胜利，很多时候我们会回头看，说“嘿，等等，你穿的是什么？”，而她已经偷偷换上了。是的，她有点劫持了这个角色，把它变成了她自己的角色。好吧，我们很享受观看这个缓慢的演变过程。这真的很有趣。是的。我想她的头发现在已经变了。我们正在等待她的服装转变。
And also we're waiting for the first Beyonce reference, which has not happened yet. Well, Brenda also, I don't know, this is maybe, was this a fast fact? Fast fact? I did discuss Brenda in fast facts, but we were going to come to you and ask you for your input about Brenda. Well, Brenda was Mindy's writing and performance partner in the play that is how I cast Mindy,
而且我们还在等待第一个碧昂丝的梗，目前还没出现。好吧，布伦达也……我不知道，这也许是一个快速事实？快速事实？我在快速事实里讨论过布伦达，但我们本来想找你，问问你关于布伦达的看法。好吧，布伦达是敏迪在话剧里的写作和表演搭档，这就是我选角敏迪的原因，
because Mindy wrote this off-Broadway play called Matt and Ben about Matt Damon and Ben Affleck writing Good Will Hunting. And Mindy played Ben Affleck writing Good Will Hunting. And Mindy played Ben Affleck, and Brenda, who's in Blue's Cruise, played Matt Damon. And it was a hilarious play. You went and saw it? Yes, I went and saw it.
因为敏迪写了一部外百老汇话剧叫《马特和本》，关于马特·达蒙和本·阿弗莱克写《心灵捕手》。敏迪扮演本·阿弗莱克，而布伦达，就是“酒水游轮”里的那个，扮演马特·达蒙。那是一部非常搞笑的话剧。你去看过？是的，我去看过。
By accident or on purpose? No, I was actually, I was a guest of my wife, Suzanne Daniels, who was a network executive, possibly at the WB at that time, I'm not exactly sure where she was working, and she went to see it to do talent scouting. And I thought it was super funny. You went with her?
是偶然还是特意？不，我其实是我妻子苏珊·丹尼尔斯的客人，她当时是一位电视网高管，可能当时在WB工作，我不确定她具体在哪里工作，她去看那部剧是为了发掘人才。我觉得它超级有趣。你和她一起去的？
Yeah, and it was great. And then by coincidence, Mindy's spec script came in, like the next day for me to read for staffing for writers. I was like, hey, wait, that's the one I just saw. Amazing. Amazing. Wow. I would have loved to seen that.
是的，那很棒。然后巧合的是，敏迪的样片剧本就在第二天送到了我手里，让我为编剧组选人。我当时想，嘿，等等，那不就是我刚看的那部吗。太神奇了。太神奇了。哇。我真希望能看到那部剧。
So, so now we have Brenda and she's like the corporate person. You guys, I just have to point out something about Brenda. I know we're not on the boat yet, but Brenda drinks the whole boat ride. She's there to check in on Michael. She has a beer in her hand. You look, look at her scenes on the boat yet, but Brenda drinks the whole boat ride. She's there to check in on Michael. She has a beer in her hand. You look, look at her scenes on the boat. She has a beer the whole time. She's at the bar.
所以，现在我们有了布伦达，她是总公司的人。伙计们，我必须指出关于布伦达的一点。我知道我们还没上船，但布伦达在整个船程中都在喝酒。她是来检查迈克尔的。她手里拿着啤酒。你看，看她在船上的场景，布伦达在整个船程中都在喝酒。她是来检查迈克尔的。她手里拿着啤酒。你看，看她在船上的场景。她一直拿着啤酒。她在吧台。
I mean, he only sees her when she's at the bar, pretty much. Pretty much. Or she walks up with a beer, like to check in on him. Wait, before we get out of the conference room scene, Phyllis broke so hard. Do you remember this? Oh, yes. Oh my gosh.
我是说，他基本上只在她去吧台时才看到她。基本上是这样。或者她拿着啤酒走过来，像是要检查他。等等，在我们离开会议室场景之前，菲利斯笑得太厉害了。你记得吗？哦，是的。天哪。
So Michael has said that the sales team could be, is like the furnace of the ship. Yes. It keeps things moving along. Yes. He compares them to the people from Titanic. Right, Titanic. And at five minutes, 20 seconds,
所以迈克尔说销售团队就像是船的熔炉。是的。它让事情继续运转。是的。他把他们比作《泰坦尼克号》里的人。对，泰坦尼克号。在5分20秒，
Phyllis has to put her head down because she starts laughing. Cause she says, she asked what the furnace does. And then at five minutes, 20 seconds, Phyllis has to put her head down because she starts laughing because she says, she asks what the furnace does. And then at five minutes, 50 seconds, she says, everyone in the engine room drown. Do you remember that? She could not get out the word drown. Like she couldn't, she just broke every time. And you can see her like starting to break. That would, that made me break on the day. Yes, me too. So sadly realized
菲利斯不得不低下头，因为她开始笑了。因为她说，她问熔炉是做什么的。然后在5分20秒，菲利斯不得不低下头，因为她开始笑了，因为她说，她问熔炉是做什么的。然后在5分50秒，她说“机舱里的每个人都淹死了”。你记得吗？她无法说出“淹死”这个词。就像她不能……她每次都笑场。你可以看到她开始笑场。那让我当天也笑场了。是的，我也是。悲伤地意识到
that everyone in the engine room drowned. She was like, but Michael, everyone drowned. Well, now we have to have the moment everyone gets on the boat. We've left the conference room. Yes. We're jumping around a little. At six minutes, 20 seconds,
机舱里的每个人都淹死了。她当时说，“但是迈克尔，每个人都淹死了”。好吧，现在我们得讲讲大家上船的时刻。我们已经离开会议室了。是的。我们跳跃着讲。在6分20秒，
Michael says that Pam is Mary Ann, Katie and Jim are the professor and ginger, Angela's Mrs. Howell, Kelly's the native, Stanley is one of the Globetrotters, Michael is a skipper, and Dwight is Gilligan. And this begins the war between Captain Jack and Captain Michael. Yes, I love that Michael has worn his captain hat to the booze crews. He has it on in the booze crews and he still has it on. And now they're having their little power struggle. Who is going to be the boss of this trip?
迈克尔说帕姆是玛丽安，凯蒂和吉姆是教授和金格，安吉拉是豪威尔夫人，凯莉是土著，斯坦利是哈林篮球队员之一，迈克尔是船长，德怀特是吉利根。这开始了杰克船长和迈克尔船长之间的战争。是的，我喜欢迈克尔戴着他的船长帽去参加酒水游轮。他在酒水游轮上戴着它，而且一直戴着。现在他们有了小小的权力斗争。谁才是这次旅行的老大？
Captain Jack is clearly gonna win. I mean, I feel like his boundary is very strong from the beginning. Very strong. And I want you to know I- We should say Captain Jack played by Rob Riggle. Yes. Who was a Marine.
杰克船长显然会赢。我是说，我觉得他的界限从一开始就很强。非常强。而且我想让你知道我……我们应该说杰克船长由罗伯·里格尔扮演。是的。他曾经是一名海军陆战队员。
Who was a Marine. Yes. And so there's a lot of authenticity to Captain Jack's by Rob Riggle. Who was a Marine. Who was a Marine. Yes, so there's a lot of authenticity to Captain Jack's military bearing there. How did you find Rob? Well, I mean, you know Rob, right? I know Rob. We talked a little bit about it in one of our fast facts,
他曾经是一名海军陆战队员。是的，所以杰克船长的军事风度有很多真实性。你是怎么找到罗伯的？好吧，我是说，你知道罗伯，对吧？我知道罗伯。我们在快速事实里谈过一点，
but Rob wanted me to give you a message as I talked to him yesterday. And he said, thank you so much. Also, he's sorry that he couldn't say Lake Wellampaw back. Rob was in the Alison Jones orbit. So, and we certainly knew about him. And I don't know whether he came in for one of the other parts.
但罗伯让我给你带个话，因为我昨天和他谈过。他说，非常感谢。另外，他很抱歉他没能说出“瓦伦帕克湖”。罗伯在艾莉森·琼斯的圈子里。所以，我们当然知道他。我不知道他是否来试镜过其他角色。
Like he might've come in for Dwight or something. I'm not a hundred percent sure. Did that happen sometimes? People who had come in for main cast members, you would ping them for a future episode? Sure, yeah. I mean, I think Alison released some of the audition tapes as part of the DVD extra,
比如他可能来试镜过德怀特之类的。我不百分之百确定。这种情况有时会发生吗？那些来试镜主要角色的演员，你会把他们留作未来剧集的备选？当然，是的。我是说，我想艾莉森发布了一些试镜带作为DVD花絮的一部分，
but there were a lot of cool people that came in. It would have been very interesting to see Seth Rogen as Dwight, for instance. Yes, definitely. Or Kristen Wiig as Pam. I think she came in to read Pam. I think she's in my site on my, on my, Alison Jones. And Catherine Hahn.
但有很多很酷的人来过。比如看到塞斯·罗根扮演德怀特会非常有趣。是的，绝对。或者克里斯汀·韦格扮演帕姆。我想她来读过帕姆的剧本。我想她在我的……在我的艾莉森·琼斯的名单上。还有凯瑟琳·哈恩。
Yeah, Alison Jones gave me my sign in sheet day and Catherine Hahn is on it and Bob Odenkirk is on it. Yeah, well Bob was really the number two. If we didn't have Steve, it would have been Bob. He did a great job. And then in season nine, we brought him back as the sort of echo. He was so fantastic too. Yeah, he did a great job. And then in season nine, we brought him back as the sort of echo. He was so fantastic too.
是的，艾莉森·琼斯给了我我的签到表，凯瑟琳·哈恩在上面，鲍勃·奥登科克也在上面。是的，鲍勃确实是第二人选。如果我们没有史蒂夫，那就会是鲍勃。他做得很好。然后在第九季，我们把他带回来作为某种回声。他太棒了。是的，他做得很好。然后在第九季，我们把他带回来作为某种回声。他太棒了。
Yeah, he's great. So I have a lot of fan questions about the boat. Sure. Okay. So since we're getting on the boat, Casey Wright asked, was the boat really moving? And Sam Pellet asked how cold it was. The boat was really moving through the water for one of the days of shooting.
是的，他很棒。所以我有很多关于船的粉丝提问。当然。好的。既然我们要上船了，凯西·赖特问，船真的在动吗？萨姆·佩莱特问当时有多冷。船在拍摄的一天里确实在水面上移动。
The other two days, I believe it was docked. And it was, the boat was really moving through the water for one of the days of shooting. The other two days, I believe it was docked and it was cold. It was December, 2005, which was chilly, especially at night out on the water. A lot of people wondered, were you pretending to be that cold? I remember being cold. Yes, I don't think there was a lot of pretending.
另外两天，我相信它是停靠着的。而且……船在拍摄的一天里确实在水面上移动。另外两天，我相信它是停靠着的，而且很冷。那是2005年12月，天气很冷，尤其是在水上的夜晚。很多人想知道，你们是在假装那么冷吗？我记得当时真的很冷。是的，我不认为有很多假装的成分。
Your cheeks are like white pink in that scene. Yes. So, Lorne Michaels has a thing that he says sometimes where like he will get in character underwear for the actors. And yeah, I think this is it. And people will say, well, why? Who cares?
在那一幕里，你们的脸颊是白里透红的。是的。所以，洛恩·迈克尔斯有一套理论，他有时会说，他会为演员准备角色内衣。是的，我想就是这样。人们会说，为什么？谁在乎呢？
That's not gonna be on camera. And he goes, yes, but the actors know. Oh, I kind of get that. Yeah. I kind of get that. I kind of get that. And so we certainly believed in that and went out on this real boat in Long Beach Harbor and it was this huge thing.
那又不会出现在镜头里。他说，是的，但演员们知道。哦，我有点理解了。是的。我有点理解了。我有点理解了。所以我们当然相信这一点，并开着这艘真正的船在长滩港航行，这是一件大事。
And to me, the key of it was that romantic scene on the top deck between Pam and Jim. And I just thought it'd be so pretty up there with the twinkling lights of the harbor and the background and everything. So we do that scene and later in the editing room somebody was like, what did you do? Did you just put a row of Christmas lights against a black piece of duveteen there and do it in a studio? And we're like, no. You know. What? We're on a boat. We're on an actual boat. But it didn't really look that impressive
对我来说，关键是帕姆和吉姆在顶层甲板上的那场浪漫戏。我只是觉得那里有港口的闪烁灯光和背景，一切都会很美。所以我们拍了那场戏，后来在剪辑室里，有人说，你们做了什么？你们是不是只是在工作室里把一串圣诞灯挂在黑色的天鹅绒布上拍的？我们说，不。你知道。什么？我们在船上。我们在真正的船上。但它看起来并没有那么令人印象深刻，
when it came down to it was just this one little twinkle thing of lights on the horizon. Like we could have been on a soundstage. Yeah, we could have been nice and toasty and comfortable. But the wind was blowing and I could, I don't know, I could tell you're on a boat. I think so. Well, one of the challenges of being on the boat
当它最终呈现出来时，只是地平线上的一点点闪烁的灯光。就像我们可以在摄影棚里拍一样。是的，我们可以待在温暖舒适的地方。但风在吹，我能……我不知道，我能看出你们在船上。我想是的。好吧，在船上的挑战之一
was how sick everyone got. Greg, do you remember that? We were all really sick. Well, one of the challenges of being on the boat was how sick everyone got. Greg, do you remember that? We were all really sick. Yeah, there was a lot of seasickness. Yeah. People were really throwing up. Yeah. I did not get seasick, but do you remember coming up to Kate Flannery and I and saying,
是每个人都病得有多厉害。格雷格，你记得吗？我们都病得很重。好吧，在船上的挑战之一是每个人都病得有多厉害。格雷格，你记得吗？我们都病得很重。是的，有很多晕船。是的。人们真的在呕吐。是的。我没有晕船，但你记得你走到凯特·弗兰纳里和我面前说，
hey, you guys, I want to get some B-roll of people vomiting off the side of the boat? Greg, do you remember? I don't, but that would be something I would have done. It was like three in the morning and you said, so you had Matt sown grab as many people as he could and we had the choice of cream of mushroom or minestrone. Craig Oh, right, right, right, the fake vomiting. Nicole The fake vomiting, the fake vomiting. And I
“嘿，伙计们，我想拍一些人们在船边呕吐的B-roll素材”吗？格雷格，你记得吗？我不记得了，但这确实是我会做的事。当时是凌晨三点，你说……所以你让马特·索恩抓尽可能多的人，我们有奶油蘑菇汤或蔬菜汤的选择。格雷格：哦，对，对，对，假呕吐。妮可：假呕吐，假呕吐。我
did, I did minestrone. Nicole Yeah, good choice. Nicole But you had to take a swig of it and hold it in your mouth until action and then puke it. And that, I don't know, five to 10 seconds you held it in your mouth was the most horrible thing because you were just like, like trying not to gag. So I didn't puke for real, but I did fake puke. Well, I got really sick, so did David Denman.
喝了蔬菜汤。妮可：好的选择。妮可：但你必须喝一口，含在嘴里直到喊“开始”，然后吐出来。那……我不知道，你含在嘴里的那5到10秒是最可怕的事情，因为你只是……试图不干呕。所以我没有真的吐，但我假装吐了。好吧，我病得很重，大卫·丹曼也是。
And I was wearing those wristbands. Yes. Did you pass out bony into or stuff? Yeah, there were all these remedies, but nothing really worked. Seasickness, gum. Someone gave me something to chew on. Maybe the gum. There's like a ginger gum. So at one point, the real captain of the boat heard that I was struggling. There were three captains. There were three captains. And then there was also, there was Dwight steering the ship and a guy and then a real guy. At one point, the real captain of the ship
我当时戴着那些腕带。是的。你晕倒了吗？是的，有各种补救措施，但没什么真正起作用。晕船口香糖。有人给了我一些东西嚼。也许是口香糖。有一种姜味口香糖。所以有一次，船上的真正船长听说我在挣扎。有三位船长。有三位船长。还有德怀特在掌舵，一个人，还有一个真正的人。有一次，船上的真正船长
heard I was struggling and he got out this oil that he rubbed behind my ears. And about 10 minutes later, I was totally fine. So I written about this in my diary. I looked it up and I found some on Amazon. Here's what's in it. Here's where we turn this whole thing into an essential oils pitch podcast. By the way, we're sponsored by... Sold by Jan, Jan's essential oils and candles. So here's what it has in it. Lavender, peppermint, chamomile,
听说我在挣扎，他拿出了这种油，擦在我的耳后。大约10分钟后，我完全好了。所以我把这件事写在日记里了。我查了一下，在亚马逊上找到了。这是它的成分。这就是我们把整件事变成精油推销播客的地方。顺便说一下，我们由……简的精油和蜡烛赞助。所以它的成分是：薰衣草、薄荷、洋甘菊、
something called ylang ylang, birch, and then it has frankincense and myrrh. That's the stuff that the wise men gave to Jesus. Two of the things. Expensive, very expensive stuff. Yeah. Fancy. Who knew?
一种叫依兰依兰的东西、桦木，还有乳香和没药。那是智者送给耶稣的东西。其中两样。昂贵，非常昂贵的东西。是的。高级。谁知道呢？
I didn't even, I mean, I know frankincense and Myrrh are real, but- I didn't know they were real. I mean- I thought they were part of a Christmas song. That's not real. But like, what are they? I guess they are what you rub behind your ears when you're seasick. It sounds like they just threw everything in the kitchen sink into this.
我甚至……我是说，我知道乳香和没药是真实存在的，但是……我不知道它们是真实存在的。我是说……我以为它们只是圣诞歌的一部分。那不是真的。但是，它们是什么？我想它们就是你晕船时擦在耳后的东西。听起来他们把厨房水槽里的所有东西都扔进去了。
Yeah. They did. The ylang ylang? I don't know. Ylang ylang. Ylang ylang. All right, so in the script, there was a scene, Greg, that as the boat is pulling away, Toby's car suddenly drives up and he,
是的。他们确实这么做了。依兰依兰？我不知道。依兰依兰。依兰依兰。好了，在剧本里，有一个场景，格雷格，当船驶离时，托比的车突然开了过来，他
and Michael yells at him from the ship, oh, come on, what's up? And he's like, I'm sorry, there was an accident or there was traffic. And then Michael says, we're not going back. We're not going back from him, just leave him. And then Paul turns to camera as Toby and he kind of gives a little wink.
迈克尔从船上对他大喊：“哦，得了吧，怎么了？”他说：“对不起，出了事故或者有交通堵塞。”然后迈克尔说：“我们不会回去的。我们不会为了他回去，让他走吧。”然后保罗作为托比转向镜头，他有点眨了眨眼。
Yeah, it's a big smile. Yeah, like he did on purpose. But you can find that in the deleted scenes. We shot it. Yes, I remember shooting that. We shot it and it was very nice. And that is why Toby is not on the boat for anyone who was wondering.
是的，是一个大大的微笑。是的，就像他是故意的。但你可以在删除片段里找到那个。我们拍了。是的，我记得拍过那个。我们拍了，而且非常好。这就是为什么托比不在船上的原因，给那些想知道的人。
Maybe we should take a- There's a lot of excuses for why Toby wouldn't be on things so that he could help out as a writer and producer. Toby and BJ and Mindy, like they sat in the, you know, Mindy was in the annex, like things like that. Yeah. I thought I was so clever in season one making them actors so that they would have this experience of being actors.
也许我们应该……有很多借口解释为什么托比不在某些场合，这样他就可以作为编剧和制片人帮忙。托比、BJ和敏迪，他们坐在……你知道，敏迪在附楼里，诸如此类。是的。我在第一季让他们当演员时，觉得我太聪明了，这样他们就能有当演员的经验。
And then at some point in season two, I'm looking around and 50% of the writers are gone because they're on set. I'm like, oh, what have I done? Okay, at seven minutes, 55 seconds, Rob Riggle breaks. He totally breaks. What? We talked about it. It just, it stayed in the shot.
然后到了第二季的某个时候，我环顾四周，50%的编剧都不见了，因为他们在片场。我当时想，哦，我做了什么？好的，在7分55秒，罗伯·里格尔笑场了。他完全笑场了。什么？我们谈过这个。它就留在了镜头里。
So Rob as Captain Jack is going over the safety features of the boat and Michael really wants to hijack this speech and give it and he can't. So he just starts doing like the flight attendant like pointing to the exits. Yeah. And Rob just breaks. He just starts laughing but he just keeps going. And then Rain as Dwight laughs. So it just sort of like but it stays in. Oh that's amazing. But Rob was like yeah I just I just laughed, but I just kept talking through my laugh. When Steve is doing his dancing, I remember trying to build the reactions because everybody's
所以罗伯作为杰克船长正在讲解船上的安全设施，迈克尔真的很想劫持这个演讲并由他来讲，但他做不到。所以他只是开始像空乘人员一样指向出口。是的。罗伯就笑场了。他只是开始笑，但他继续讲下去。然后雷恩作为德怀特也笑了。所以它就……但它留在了片子里。哦，那太神奇了。但罗伯当时就像是，是的，我只是……我只是笑了，但我边笑边继续讲。当史蒂夫跳舞时，我记得我试图建立反应，因为每个人都
supposed to be unimpressed and just straight faced. And it was almost impossible because everybody was breaking. We made him do that over and over and over again. For so long. I remember when we rewatched it, I just wrote, oh my gosh, Michael's dance because he danced for so long. In my journal, I said that we started taping that around 2 a.m. It was really late. A fan question from Tara Leitchke, was Steve's dance choreographed? I don't think so. I really think he improvised that. I don't remember it being in the script.
应该表现得不为所动，面无表情。这几乎是不可能的，因为每个人都在笑场。我们让他一遍又一遍地做。做了很久。我记得当我们重看时，我只是写道：“天哪，迈克尔的舞”，因为他跳了太久了。在我的日记里，我说我们大约在凌晨2点开始拍摄。真的很晚。粉丝提问，来自塔拉·莱奇克，史蒂夫的舞是编排好的吗？我不这么认为。我真的觉得他是即兴发挥的。我不记得剧本里有这个。
I think he just kind of went for it. I have the script at home for this episode and I read it and there is no direction for Michael's dance in the script. It just says, pan over to see Michael doing a weird dance. That's it. That's as much as there was. Another fan question about the dance, Steve Dresser says, how many takes of that superb dance did it take to get Steve's full moves? I'm gonna say about six, I think.
我想他只是随性发挥。我家里有这一集的剧本，我读过，剧本里没有关于迈克尔跳舞的指示。上面只写着：镜头扫过，看到迈克尔在跳一段奇怪的舞。就是这样。这就是全部内容。另一个关于舞蹈的粉丝提问，史蒂夫·德雷瑟问，那段精彩的舞蹈拍了多少次才拍到史蒂夫的全套动作？我想大约六次吧。
What do you think? What do you remember? That seems about right. I can't remember when he started slapping his think. Yeah. What do you think? What do you remember? That seems about right. I can't remember when he started slapping his legs. Yeah, that was amazing. If that was early on or later. And the worm. I mean, they were different.
你觉得呢？你记得什么？那听起来差不多。我不记得他什么时候开始拍打他的……是的。你觉得呢？你记得什么？那听起来差不多。我不记得他什么时候开始拍打他的腿。是的，那太神奇了。如果那是早期还是后期。还有“蠕虫舞”。我是说，它们是不同的。
I feel like there were different versions of the dance, and then we kind of made the highlight reel in the other room. Yes. And there's, on the deleted scenes, you can see even more of the dancing, if you want to. I remember when Ken finally was like, okay, cut, Steve was on the ground doing the last worm.
我觉得舞蹈有不同的版本，然后我们在另一个房间里剪辑出了精华片段。是的。而且，在删除片段里，如果你想看的话，可以看到更多的舞蹈。我记得当肯终于喊“好，停”时，史蒂夫正趴在地上做最后一个蠕虫动作。
Yeah, that was the last one, yeah. And he got up and everyone applauded for him. And like, you guys came over and gave him a hug because he had really gone for it. That was exhausting. Yeah, he completely did. That was amazing. Here's a fan question.
是的，那是最后一个，是的。他站起来，每个人都为他鼓掌。而且……你们走过去给了他一个拥抱，因为他真的全力以赴了。那太累人了。是的，他完全做到了。那太棒了。这是一个粉丝提问。
Was there music playing when Michael danced or was it added later? My memory is that it was added later. I mean, I feel like what we often did was we would do one take with the music and then somebody would have a little earwig, you know, and they would say, do you want to do it with an earwig? And a lot of effort had gone into making a tiny invisible thing that could play the soundtrack and then the actor would go, no, I don't need it. And then it was to do the next five takes just for memory.
迈克尔跳舞时有音乐吗，还是后来加的？我的记忆是后来加的。我是说，我觉得我们经常做的是，我们用音乐拍一次，然后有人会戴着小耳机，你知道，他们会说，你想戴着耳机做吗？而且为了制作一个可以播放配乐的微小隐形装置花了很多精力，然后演员会说，不，我不需要。然后就是为了记忆再拍接下来的五次。
That's how I feel like it probably went down. I do remember some fun facts about the band on Booze Cruise. Yes, we had a lot of questions about the band. Yes, exactly, because my friend Bob Thiel Jr., as you were pointing out on your card, who did our theme song was in the band. And three out of the four band people were the guys who played our theme song, Hal Craigin and Dylan O'Brien, who's a big songwriter in LA. And these guys were friends of mine, or Bob was. And the theme song for The Office
我觉得大概就是这样。我确实记得关于“酒水游轮”乐队的一些趣事。是的，我们有很多关于乐队的问题。是的，没错，因为我的朋友鲍勃·蒂尔二世，正如你在卡片上指出的，他创作了我们的主题曲，他就在乐队里。四个乐队成员中有三个是演奏我们主题曲的人，哈尔·克雷金和迪伦·奥布莱恩，他是洛杉矶的一位大词曲作者。这些人是我的朋友，或者鲍勃是。而《办公室》的主题曲
was written by Jay Ferguson, but he set over a version of it on synthesizer, which was a little, it was great. It was obviously a great song, loved it, but it didn't sound, didn't have the energy that you'd want. And so Bob had this kind of rockin' band that he put together of his friends, and we went and recorded the theme song with all live instruments in a session.
是由杰伊·弗格森创作的，但他用合成器录制了一个版本，虽然有点……但很棒。这显然是一首很棒的歌，我很喜欢，但听起来没有你想要的那种活力。所以鲍勃组建了一支由他朋友组成的摇滚乐队，我们就在录音室里用现场乐器录制了这首主题曲。
Yeah. That is so cool, I did not know that. Yeah. That is so cool. I did not know that. Yeah. That is so cool. And then he became, you know, then he called his band the Scrantones. Yeah. And then he came to Scranton with us
是啊。太酷了，我以前都不知道。是啊。太酷了。我以前都不知道。是啊。太酷了。然后他成了……你知道，后来他把他的乐队叫作“斯克兰顿人”（The Scrantones）。是啊。然后他跟我们一起去了斯克兰顿。
and would play at our parties often. And he was in the, I had a fan write in and say that he's also in Phyllis's wedding with Kevin in Scrantonicity. I had a fan as well. Vanessa McLoad said that she noticed that at least one of the band members shows up later in Scrantonicity at Phyllis's wedding. Yeah, it's Bob. Oh. Bob also did music, the music for Sons of Anarchy and the Mayans, so he's quite talented.
并且经常在我们的派对上演奏。有个粉丝写信来说，他还和凯文一起出现在菲利斯的婚礼上，在“斯克兰顿之城”（Scrantonicity）乐队里。我也收到了一位粉丝的来信。凡妮莎·麦克劳德说她注意到至少有一位乐队成员后来出现在菲利斯婚礼上的“斯克兰顿之城”乐队里。是啊，那是鲍勃。哦。鲍勃还为《混乱之子》和《玛雅帮》创作了音乐，所以他非常有才华。
He's so talented. I have it 11 minutes, 14 seconds. This is really crazy if you know these three people. Phyllis, Kevin, and Angela are dancing together. Oh! What? I'm telling you. Isn't there a shot of Phyllis dancing with Creed at one point? Yes, yes. Towards the end, there is, they're dancing together,
他太有才华了。我记的是11分14秒。如果你认识这三个人，这真的很疯狂。菲利斯、凯文和安吉拉正在一起跳舞。哦！什么？我跟你说。有一幕不是菲利斯在和克里德跳舞吗？是的，是的。在快结束的时候，确实有，他们在跳舞。
but we're doing that awkward dance, where like, I almost feel like an eighth grade, where like a group of girls dance together. Except it's me, Phyllis and Kevin. We're just kind of doing like a little sway like that. It's just very funny to me. Well, I don't know if you remember Greg, but there was a runner, I read it in the script, and then I went back and I saw it in the deleted scenes. There was this whole runner through this episode that Oscar is a really mean drunk. Yes. I'm glad we cut that. So on the booze cruise.
但我们跳的是那种尴尬的舞，就像……我感觉像八年级学生一样，一群女孩在一起跳舞。只不过是我、菲利斯和凯文。我们只是像那样轻轻摇摆。这对我来说太搞笑了。好吧，我不知道你还记不记得格雷格，剧本里有个连贯情节，我读过，后来我回去看了删减片段。这一集里有个贯穿始终的情节，说奥斯卡是个酒品很差的醉鬼。是的。我很高兴我们删掉了。就是在游轮派对上。
Yeah. I didn't like that. I re-read the script too and I was like, ooh, glad we didn't use this. Oh my gosh. Where he's just, he's getting drunk and then he's going around and he's insulting all of you. So that is probably why Oscar is not dancing with you guys. And also later- He's isolated himself. Yeah, later it's just Kevin and I in the booth. And that's probably why.
是啊。我不喜欢那个。我也重读了剧本，当时我就想，噢，幸好我们没用这个。天哪。就是他喝醉了，然后到处去侮辱你们所有人。所以这可能就是为什么奥斯卡没有和你们一起跳舞。而且后来……他把自己孤立起来了。是啊，后来只有我和凯文在小隔间里。这可能就是原因。
Because Oscar's off talking about you. Oh, I forgot about that. Well, I wanna go back to the scene with Jim, Katie, Pam, and Roy sitting around the table. Great. Katie makes a comment where she says, ah, we're at the cool table. And then they all talk about what they were like in high school, except Jim. We don't hear about Jim, but we find out that Katie was a cheerleader and that Pam was artsy fartsy, thanks Roy, and that Roy played sports. And then Amy does her little cheer, Amy as Katie does her awesome cheer,
因为奥斯卡在外面说你们的坏话。哦，我忘了那件事了。好吧，我想回到吉姆、凯蒂、帕姆和罗伊坐在桌子旁的那场戏。太棒了。凯蒂评论说，啊，我们坐在酷桌这边。然后他们都谈论了自己在高中的样子，除了吉姆。我们没听到关于吉姆的事，但我们发现凯蒂以前是啦啦队长，帕姆是个文艺青年——多谢罗伊——而罗伊以前是搞体育的。然后艾米跳了她的小啦啦操，艾米作为凯蒂跳了她那段很棒的啦啦操。
and that was not in the script. We found out on the set that Amy Adams was a cheerleader and she knew a bunch of cheers and you had her do little cheers for us to react to. Amy and I did a few cheers together. We were all really punchy, you guys. It was like three in the morning. So do you remember?
那不在剧本里。我们在片场发现艾米·亚当斯以前是啦啦队长，她会跳很多啦啦操，你就让她跳给我们看，让我们做出反应。艾米和我一起跳了几段。我们当时都特别兴奋，伙计们。那时候都凌晨三点了。所以你还记得吗？
Because I remember when we were doing that scene and Amy started to do the cheerleader stuff, we did a couple of takes of it. And then Ken wanted to move on. And something was bothering me. And I didn't want to move on from that scene. And I realized that the balance, she kind of shifted the balance.
因为我记得我们在拍那场戏时，艾米开始跳啦啦操，我们拍了几条。然后肯想继续拍下一场。但我心里有点不对劲。我不想就这么跳过那场戏。我意识到那种平衡感，她稍微打破了平衡。
Because Amy Adams, obviously very charismatic, yeah, you know, beautiful actress, and she did that really fun, cute cheerleader thing. And then we were going to move on. And I realized like, Pam is just basically not participating on the same level here. She's kind of denying the cheerleader thing, but she isn't doing her own charismatic thing. And we went back and at 909, I went back to you and I said, you got to kick this up a notch, do something. Do you remember that? Yeah. And then you kind of mocked her cheerleader thing. You did that and I was like, yeah. Yeah. Because that was not in the script. That wasn't. That was added in the moment. Yeah. And that's, yeah, I kind of flirt with Jim there.
因为艾米·亚当斯显然非常有魅力，你知道，美丽的演员，她跳了那个非常有趣、可爱的啦啦操。然后我们就要继续拍下一场了。我意识到帕姆基本上没有参与到同样的水平。她有点在否认啦啦队长那件事，但她自己并没有展现出那种魅力。我们回去拍了909场，我回到你身边说，你得加把劲，做点什么。你还记得吗？是啊。然后你有点嘲弄了她的啦啦操。你做了那个动作，我就想，对，就是这样。因为那不在剧本里。确实不在。那是临时加的。是啊，而且……是啊，我在那里有点和吉姆调情。
I have a private moment at the table. I thought that was like so bold with Roy sitting next to you. Like when I watched it again, I was like, wait, she's flirting with Jim with Roy next to her and also kind of making fun of Katie. Yeah. I was like, Pam's having a moment.
我在桌子旁有一个私人的时刻。我觉得在罗伊坐在你旁边的情况下这太大胆了。当我再看一遍时，我就想，等等，她在罗伊旁边和吉姆调情，还顺便嘲笑了凯蒂。是啊。我就想，帕姆正在经历一个特别的时刻。
Well, I think it was an important connection there, Greg, because it is certainly gonna help give Jim the courage to do what he's going to attempt to do, which is tell Pam his feelings. I think without that little moment of them bonding over how ridiculous their significant others are being, it's like you need to see them as that bonded couple. So it doesn't come so out of the blue that Jim would think, this could be my moment.
嗯，我认为那是一个重要的连接点，格雷格，因为它肯定会帮助吉姆鼓起勇气去做他打算做的事，那就是告诉帕姆他的感受。我认为如果没有他们因为另一半表现得如此荒谬而产生共鸣的那一刻，你就需要看到他们作为那种有羁绊的一对。这样吉姆觉得“这可能是我的机会”就不会显得那么突兀了。
Well, also Pam really gives them an opening on the top of the boat there. She does. Yeah. That to me, the Jim thing of it was she's engaged and he wants to be a good person and respect the fact that she's engaged. But he's also like, there's all these clues coming in that there could be something and he doesn't go for it. It's very frustrating to watch.
嗯，而且帕姆在船顶上确实给了他们一个机会。她确实给了。是啊。对我来说，吉姆那部分的问题在于她已经订婚了，他想做一个好人，尊重她已经订婚的事实。但他同时也觉得，所有这些线索都表明他们之间可能有什么，但他没有采取行动。看的时候真的很让人沮丧。
It's so painful to watch, but also feels so honest. Yeah. Because that's how you would be. You'd want to say everything, and you wouldn't be able to. Well, I remember, to me, that was probably one of the most personal and sort of raw things that I would have put into a script, because it did not feel like a very,
看的时候太痛苦了，但也感觉非常真实。是啊。因为这就是你会有的反应。你想说出一切，但你却做不到。嗯，我记得，对我来说，那可能是我写进剧本里最个人化、最原始的东西之一，因为它感觉不像是一个……
like noble Jim successful social guy moment. It felt really like, people are gonna hate him for this or disrespect him or whatever. So I kind of felt it was risky to put it out there. I don't know, it was very hard also in the edit to keep it that long. I mean, we tried to make the same length
不像是一个高尚的吉姆、成功的社交达人的时刻。它感觉真的很像，人们会因为这个讨厌他或不尊重他之类的。所以我当时觉得把它放出来很有风险。我不知道，在剪辑时保持那么长时间也很难。我的意思是，我们试图保持同样的长度。
that you guys really did in the scene and there was a lot of urge to like trim that up. That's an awful long time to have people not talk. Yes, let's talk about that. It's so beautiful, it's so beautiful. Pam and Jim are on the deck of that boat and Pam does give him an opening. She says, sometimes I just don't get Roy. And this is the first time we've seen her complain about Roy to Jim to disparage her relationship. Really, it's
你们在戏里确实做到了，而且当时有很大的冲动想把它剪短。让人们沉默那么久真是太长了。是的，我们来谈谈那个。太美了，太美了。帕姆和吉姆在船的甲板上，帕姆确实给了他一个机会。她说，有时候我就是不明白罗伊。这是我们第一次看到她向吉姆抱怨罗伊，贬低她的关系。真的，这是
the first time she's verbalized it. I'm't, I'm pretty sure. And then it is 27 seconds of silence. And a fan wrote in Anthony Snead said, what was the motivation behind that awkward silence? There's a lot going on in those 27 seconds, just because people aren't talking doesn't mean nothing's going on. And I think that you look at his face and you can see him trying out different things and thinking and being urged to go forward and blocked and, you know, and then I think also on your face, there's all this kind of like disappointment
她第一次把它说出来。我敢肯定。然后是27秒的沉默。一位粉丝安东尼·斯尼德写信问，那段尴尬沉默背后的动机是什么？在那27秒里发生了很多事，只是因为人们没说话并不代表什么都没发生。我认为你看着他的脸，你可以看到他在尝试不同的事情，在思考，在被敦促前进和被阻挡之间挣扎，你知道，然后我也认为在你的脸上，有一种……失望。
that he's not gonna do anything and face saving when you're like, well, I'm cold. And it was kind of good that it was cold actually. And we really did shoot it out in the harbor because I think you wouldn't have been able to, like your nose was red. And you know what I mean? It was like-
他什么都没做，当你像说“好吧，我冷了”时，你在挽回面子。其实冷一点挺好的。我们确实是在港口实地拍摄的，因为我觉得你不可能……你的鼻子都红了。你知道我的意思吗？就像……
I was cold. Yeah, you were cold. Yeah, I believed it. Now, Greg, it wasn't in the script that there would be a big pause. It didn't say there's a long, big pause. It just says that they look at each other and then finally Pam says.
我很冷。是啊，你很冷。是啊，我相信了。现在，格雷格，剧本里并没有写会有长时间的停顿。上面没写“有长时间的停顿”。只是说他们看着对方，然后帕姆终于说了话。
But I remember on the day you really encouraging us to take our time and don't be afraid to just look at each other. Well, I mean, that was part of, I think, what made the show so special was that, and so different from what was on TV, was that moments of behavior were really important, more so than jokes and setups
但我记得那天你真的鼓励我们慢慢来，不要害怕只是看着对方。嗯，我的意思是，我认为这正是让这部剧如此特别、与电视上其他节目如此不同的原因，那就是行为的时刻比笑话、铺垫、
and punch lines and lines and stuff. And I think that came out of appreciating what's good about a documentary. And documentaries just are all about finding the truth in what people are doing and leaning in. And no matter what they think they're doing or what they say they're doing, what are their actions show you that they're doing? And this was like a good romantic example of it all being in between the lines and it all being on the
妙语和台词之类的东西更重要。我认为这源于对纪录片优点的欣赏。纪录片就是关于在人们所做的事情中寻找真相并深入挖掘。无论他们认为自己在做什么，或者他们说自己在做什么，他们的行动向你展示了他们在做什么？这是一个很好的浪漫例子，一切都在字里行间，一切都在
faces and not in the script. That is so smartly said. You guys, should we talk about what else was going on during this scene? Do you mean when half of the cast got lost at sea? Yes. All right, so here's the deal. When we started this scene, I think we knew it was gonna take a while. And so they told the other cast members
脸上，而不是在剧本里。说得太聪明了。伙计们，我们要谈谈这场戏期间还发生了什么吗？你是说当半个剧组在海上迷路的时候？是的。好吧，事情是这样的。当我们开始这场戏时，我想我们知道这会花点时间。所以他们告诉其他演员
that they could leave for the day, but the only way to get off the boat, because we weren't gonna take the boat back and dock it. No, there were these little dinghies that would pull up and you would get in the little boat and it would take you to shore. Exactly. Well, that did not go as planned.
他们可以先走，但离开船的唯一方法——因为我们不会把船开回去靠岸——不，有那些小艇会靠过来，你坐进小船，它会把你带到岸上。没错。好吧，那并没有按计划进行。
No, it didn't. I remember getting this panicky radio thing. The boat with Phyllis on it is gone. Look, look at my card. Were you, you were on the boat too. I was stranded on the boat. And Brian too, right? And Rain, and I wrote about it in my journal.
没有，并没有。我记得收到这个惊慌失措的无线电消息。载着菲利斯的船不见了。看，看我的卡片。你当时也在船上。我被困在船上了。布莱恩也在，对吧？还有雷恩，我在日记里写过这件事。
Yeah. Yeah, okay, so- It was crazy. Well, for some reason it fixated on me that it was Phyllis. That Phyllis was, that we had, we had lost Phyllis. She seems like the most vulnerable of the group. Right? Kind Phyllis. Yeah. So, um, so I wrote her about it and she- I can't wait to hear what she says. Well, she says the first memory, she said it was about 2 30 in the morning and she was waiting to leave, uh, the ship And her first memory was seeing Steve Carell
是啊。是啊，好吧，所以……太疯狂了。嗯，出于某种原因，我认定是菲利斯。菲利斯……我们把菲利斯弄丢了。她看起来是这群人里最脆弱的一个。对吧？善良的菲利斯。是啊。所以，嗯，所以我写了关于她的事，她……我迫不及待想听听她怎么说。嗯，她说第一个记忆，她说当时大约凌晨2点30分，她正在等候离开那艘船。她的第一个记忆是看到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔
on a tiny little boat holding onto some kind of a pole with no life jacket disappearing into the night. And she remembers thinking that if NBC knew that their star didn't have a life jacket and was being pulled off back to the harbor, they would be upset. And then she got on the boat and she thought it was Oscar, Brian, and somebody from the wardrobe department. I wrote about it the day of.
在一艘小船上，抓着某种杆子，没有救生衣，消失在夜色中。她记得当时想，如果NBC知道他们的明星没有救生衣，正被拖回港口，他们会很生气的。然后她上了船，她以为那是奥斯卡、布莱恩和服装部门的某个人。我当天就写下来了。
But that was you. Oh, she says, I'm not sure if Angela was there or not. And then she talks to, everything was fine pulling away. We were enjoying the smell of the ocean, the lights in the distance. And then all of a sudden, nothing, the engine died. So you were there. So this is what I wrote the day after we filmed the scene.
但那是你。哦，她说，我不确定安吉拉是否在那里。然后她谈到，离开时一切都很顺利。我们正在享受海洋的气味，远处的灯光。然后突然，什么都没有了，引擎熄火了。所以你当时也在。这就是我拍完那场戏的第二天写的。
All right, I wrote, one of the coolest things that happened to me while we shot this episode happened the last night, or I guess I should say the morning of, Ray and Phyllis and Brian and I were all wrapped at 5.30 a.m. We were on the main boat, but they said they had more shooting to do so we could stay on the big boat and sleep in a booth.
好吧，我写道，拍摄这一集时发生在我身上最酷的事情之一发生在最后一晚，或者我应该说是凌晨，雷恩、菲利斯、布莱恩和我都在凌晨5点30分收工了。我们在主船上，但他们说还有拍摄任务，所以我们可以留在大船上，睡在小隔间里。
Yeah. Or they said they had these little rubber boats that would pull up next to the big boat that we could get on and they would take us to shore. So we said, okay, we'll do that. They said it's about a 15 minute boat ride on the little rubber dinghy. So we decided to do it.
是啊。或者他们说有这些小橡皮艇会靠在大船旁边，我们可以上去，他们会带我们去岸上。所以我们说，好吧，我们就那样做。他们说坐小橡皮艇去岸上大约需要15分钟。所以我们决定那样做。
It was really tricky getting on the little rubber dinghy. So we decided to do it. It was really tricky getting on the rubber boat. We just had to climb out a ladder off the side of the boat. And these guys- It was very unstable. Phyllis said that at one point she had to switch boats. She was terrified of falling in. Yes. And I said, okay, the little rubber boat, picture the kind of like rubber boat that the Navy SEALs do the the back flips off of with the little like me like outboat. That's what this looked like. So we're lowered down into it. And it was me, Rain, Jen, one of our wardrobe gals, Phyllis and Brian. It was tiny and really
上小橡皮艇真的很棘手。所以我们决定那样做。上橡皮艇真的很棘手。我们不得不从船侧爬下梯子。这些人……非常不稳定。菲利斯说有一次她不得不换船。她害怕掉下去。是的。我说，好吧，小橡皮艇，想象一下那种海军海豹突击队会从上面后空翻下来的橡皮艇，带着那种像……舷外马达。这就是它看起来的样子。所以我们被降到里面。里面有我、雷恩、简、我们的一位服装师、菲利斯和布莱恩。它很小，而且非常
bouncy. We took off. It was dark out and the ocean looked like black glass. It was very peaceful. Oh, it's so poetic. Yeah. Sorry. About five minutes into our ride, our engine made a weird worrying sound and stopped working. And then we heard the boat driver radio and say, the engine's dead, you need to come get us. Brian started laughing and said, you've got to be kidding me. Then we just floated in the darkness, which felt like for a while. It was quiet and peaceful. It turned into the Titanic.
颠簸。我们出发了。外面很黑，海洋看起来像黑色的玻璃。非常平静。哦，太诗意了。抱歉。航行了大约五分钟后，我们的引擎发出奇怪的嗡嗡声，然后停止工作了。然后我们听到船夫用无线电说，引擎坏了，你们需要来接我们。布莱恩开始大笑，说，你们一定是在开玩笑。然后我们就漂浮在黑暗中，感觉过了很久。非常安静和平静。它变成了《泰坦尼克号》。
I know, I know. And then we, another rubber boat pulled up and then we had to just straddle from one rubber boat with just two guys kind of holding it together into the other one. This was very tricky. We slowly made our way past the Queen Mary, picture an old cruise ship that looks like the Titanic. And there was a huge plume of fire coming
我知道，我知道。然后我们……另一艘橡皮艇靠了过来，我们不得不从一艘橡皮艇跨到另一艘上，只有两个人在那儿扶着。这非常棘手。我们慢慢经过玛丽皇后号，想象一艘看起来像泰坦尼克号的老式游轮。后面有一团巨大的火球
from a refinery behind it. Rain said to me, this is so surreal. And that's exactly what it was. You know, the wheels really came off when we went on locations. We talked about this a little bit. I mean, you know, this is for season nine, but death bus almost killed us all. Work bus, I should say. We've called it death bus for so long. The cast calls it death bus. All right, well, we'll take a break and we'll be back.
从后面的炼油厂冒出来。雷恩对我说，这太超现实了。而这正是它的样子。你知道，当我们去外景拍摄时，情况真的失控了。我们稍微谈过这个。我的意思是，你知道，这是第九季的事，但“死亡巴士”差点害死我们所有人。应该说是“工作巴士”。我们叫它“死亡巴士”太久了。演员们叫它“死亡巴士”。好吧，我们休息一下，马上回来。
Sick of dreaming smaller? Sick of investing but not seeing your money grow? and I'll see you next time. financial future you deserve. Get yours, Questrade. Starring Kaylee Cuoco and Chris Messina. The only investigating I'm doing these days is who pooped their pants. Killer messaged you yesterday? This is so dangerous. I gotta get out of this. Based on a true story. New season Mondays only on W. Stream live and on demand on Stack TV. Are you crushing your bills? Defeating your monthly payments. Sounds like you're at the top of your financial game.
厌倦了梦想太小？厌倦了投资却看不到钱增长？下次见。你应得的财务未来。去获取吧，Questrade。由凯莉·库柯和克里斯·梅西纳主演。我最近做的唯一调查就是谁拉裤子里了。杀手昨天给你发信息了？这太危险了。我得离开这里。根据真实故事改编。新一季每周一仅在W频道播出。在Stack TV上直播和点播。你在还清账单吗？战胜你的月供。听起来你在财务游戏中处于领先地位。
Rise to it with the BMO Eclipse Rise Visa Card, the credit card that rewards your good financial habits. Earn points for paying your credit card bill in full and on time every month. Level up from bill payer to reward slayer. Terms and conditions apply. All right. So we are back from break. I have a question for you, Greg. Yeah. All right, so we are back from break.
用BMO Eclipse Rise Visa卡提升自己，这张信用卡奖励你良好的财务习惯。每月全额按时支付信用卡账单即可赚取积分。从账单支付者升级为奖励猎手。条款和条件适用。好吧。我们休息回来了。我有一个问题要问你，格雷格。是啊。好吧，我们休息回来了。
I have a question for you, Greg. Yeah. I've been waiting to ask you this. I know we're sort of jumping around with time codes, but at 11 minutes, 34 seconds, there's this beautiful shot that goes outside of the boat and goes around the boat. You pass Dwight, right, like steering, and it goes around the boat. How did we do that? That is Kent Zbornak.
我有一个问题要问你，格雷格。是啊。我一直在等机会问你这个。我知道我们在时间码上有点跳跃，但在11分34秒，有一个美丽的镜头，从船外绕着船拍。你经过德怀特，对吧，他在掌舵，然后绕着船拍。我们是怎么做到的？那是肯特·兹博纳克。
So Kent was our line producer, and he was also in the DGA. And he managed to launch us on the budget that we had, which was tiny, into Long Beach Harbor on a boat for days and get hotel rooms for everybody and He realized that we really needed that a shot like that and he shot that himself with his own equipment You know while we were shooting the rest of it Because he just had an instinct that there was no way the production could get that and stop everything and you know
所以肯特是我们的制片主任，他也是美国导演工会（DGA）的成员。他设法在我们拥有的预算内——那预算少得可怜——让我们在长滩港的一艘船上待了几天，并为每个人安排了酒店房间，而且他意识到我们确实需要那样的一个镜头，于是他用自己的设备亲自拍摄了那个镜头。你知道，在我们拍摄其余部分的时候。因为他有一种直觉，制作组不可能搞定那个镜头，然后停下所有事情，你知道……
so that was kind of a guerrilla move and super valuable. And Kent was fantastic at doing those kinds of things. Like he was always stitching together amazing stuff on our little budget. That is so cool. I did not know that. Did you?
所以那是一种游击式的举动，非常有价值。肯特在做这类事情方面非常出色。他总是能在我们微薄的预算下拼凑出令人惊叹的东西。太酷了。我以前都不知道。你知道吗？
No. When I saw it, I was like, wait, I know Randall and Matt were inside with us. Yeah, who did that, right? Our camera guys. I was like, how did that happen? And then I was like, is that a plane? It's in the air. Is it a drone? What is it? He's on one of those dinghies. He's on one of those zodiac dinghies. He's on a dinghy. Okay. All right. Wow.
不知道。当我看到它时，我就想，等等，我知道兰德尔和马特当时和我们在一起。是啊，那是谁拍的，对吧？我们的摄影师。我就想，那是怎么发生的？然后我就想，那是飞机吗？它在空中。是无人机吗？那是什么？他在那些小艇上。他在那些Zodiac小艇上。他在小艇上。好吧。好吧。哇。
This is another question about a camera movement. So, you know, after they're at the bar and they're all talking about who they would save, Jim gets up his courage and he's going to walk over to Pam and he says, I would save the receptionist. I think I need to make that clear. Well, right before that, Greg Phelps noticed at 14 minutes, 37 seconds, there's a continuous shot of Jim looking down the length of the boat to Pam as he thinks about who he would save. The camera then zooms in on Pam at the exact moment
这是关于摄像机运动的另一个问题。所以，你知道，在他们在酒吧里谈论他们会救谁之后，吉姆鼓起勇气，他要走向帕姆，他说，我会救前台。我想我需要说清楚。嗯，就在那之前，格雷格·菲尔普斯注意到在14分37秒，有一个吉姆沿着船身看向帕姆的连续镜头，当时他在想他会救谁。摄像机随后在帕姆的瞬间拉近了镜头
she has a really cute laughing smile. How did you time that out so perfectly? He wants to know, Jenna, were you given a cue when the camera was about to zoom in on you? But we used to do that stuff all the time. That was... Go ahead. Yeah.
她有一个非常可爱的笑脸。你是怎么把时间掐得那么准的？他想知道，珍娜，当摄像机要拉近你时，你得到提示了吗？但我们以前经常做那种事。那是……继续。是啊。
People, I think, have the wrong idea about how we did the show in a way, because most filmmaking is super intentional. And you would say to the camera operator, okay, at this signal, you need to zoom in, and then you'd try and get the actor to do it at exactly the right time. And our show was more like the theory of natural selection, kind of. Like, there would be a situation and I would give notes or the directors would give notes to the camera operators that were not about what they did specifically, but more about their intentions. So we would say, okay, you're really interested in what he sees down at the end of the hall,
人们，我认为，对我们如何制作这部剧有错误的理解，因为大多数电影制作是非常刻意的。你会对摄像师说，好的，在这个信号下，你需要拉近镜头，然后你会尝试让演员在完全正确的时间做出来。而我们的剧更像是自然选择理论，某种程度上。就像，会有一个情况，我会给笔记，或者导演会给摄像师笔记，不是关于他们具体做什么，而是更多关于他们的意图。所以我们会说，好的，你真的对他在大厅尽头看到的东西很感兴趣，
so just go find it. And we had all these people who'd come from reality shows who were used to finding the story on their own. And that turned out great, you know? And I can't really speak for Ken as the director, he directed it and he might've known exactly what he was going for and kept doing it until he got it. But a lot of the times,
所以就去找到它。我们有所有这些来自真人秀的人，他们习惯于自己寻找故事。结果证明这很棒，你知道吗？我不能真正代表肯作为导演发言，他执导了那一集，他可能确切地知道他想要什么，并一直拍到他得到它为止。但很多时候，
there were just lots of happy accidents. And then you'd tell the story through all the happy accidents and you had enough like flexibility that you could have gone a bunch of different ways with it. I think our editors don't get enough credit. Well, first of all, I think our camera operators don't get enough credit for all of those happy accidents. But then you would assemble those with the editors in the editing room.
有很多快乐的意外。然后你通过所有的快乐意外来讲述故事，你有足够的灵活性，你可以用很多不同的方式来处理它。我认为我们的剪辑师没有得到足够的赞誉。嗯，首先，我认为我们的摄像师没有因为所有那些快乐的意外而得到足够的赞誉。但你会在剪辑室里把那些和剪辑师组装在一起。
Yeah. To tell even more of a story than what was in the script. Totally, the editors are amazing. We had fantastic editors. This one was Dean. Dave Rogers is, you know, I'm still working with, work with him all the time. Brilliant. Claire Scanlon.
是啊。来讲述比剧本里更多的故事。完全正确，剪辑师们太棒了。我们有出色的剪辑师。这一集是迪恩。戴夫·罗杰斯是，你知道，我还在和他合作，一直和他一起工作。天才。克莱尔·斯坎伦。
Claire Scanlon. Also brilliant. And there was enormous amounts of leeway for the editors and in post, because like a documentary, we shot way more stuff than we could ever possibly use. And so our rough cuts were always about 38 minutes long, but the show's only 21 minutes, you know, six seconds or something like that.
克莱尔·斯坎伦。也是天才。而且剪辑师在后期有巨大的余地，因为像纪录片一样，我们拍摄的东西远比我们可能使用的要多。所以我们的粗剪版总是大约38分钟长，但剧集只有21分钟，你知道，6秒左右之类的。
So tons of good material was discarded. And that was like a large part of my job. Like I loved being on set, and I also loved being with the writers, but this whole other area of my job was sitting with the editors, and they're fun people too with great creative ideas. And you could tell so many different versions of the show by what you left in and what you took out.
所以大量的优质素材被丢弃了。那是我工作的一大部分。就像我喜欢在片场，我也喜欢和编剧们在一起，但我工作的这整个其他领域是和剪辑师坐在一起，他们也是有趣的人，有很棒的创意。你可以通过你留下的和删掉的东西来讲述这部剧的许多不同版本。
And there was always a thing where you'd go, everybody kind of agreed on the first six or eight minutes to get rid of, you know. And probably we all agreed having Oscar make snarking mean comments is not great or whatever it is. But then you get to like about 26 minutes and there was a lot of really good stuff. And I used to have all these regrets
而且总是有那种情况，你会说，每个人都同意删掉前六到八分钟，你知道。可能我们都同意让奥斯卡发表刻薄的评论并不好之类的。但当你到大约26分钟时，有很多非常好的东西。我过去常有所有的遗憾
about things that were great that couldn't get in the show. One of them for this, if you remember was Creed sitting in with the band and us finding out that he'd been in the grassroots. And that was like fantastic. And we had all this footage and I found footage of him from late sixties and playing guitar with the grassroots on Playboy After Dark with Hugh Hefner
关于那些很棒但无法进入剧集的东西。其中之一，如果你还记得，是克里德和乐队一起演奏，我们发现他曾经在“草根乐队”（The Grass Roots）里。那真是太棒了。我们有所有这些镜头，我找到了他60年代末在休·赫夫纳的《花花公子深夜秀》上和草根乐队一起弹吉他的镜头
and like all this great footage which was gonna be the B-roll under him talking about playing with all these greats in the late sixties. And that was in for a really long time. the B-roll under him talking about playing with all these greats in the late 60s. And that was in for a really long time. I think it's in the DVD extras. It is, it's in the deleted scenes. It's great. Michael, the guitar player is gonna take a break
还有所有这些很棒的镜头，本来要作为他谈论60年代末与所有这些伟人一起演奏时的B-roll（辅助镜头）。那在里面放了很长时间。我想它在DVD花絮里。是的，它在删减片段里。太棒了。迈克尔，吉他手要休息一下
and then Michael tries to fill in for him and he's horrible. And then Creed says, let me give it a shot. And then he just gets up there and rocks out. And it's so cool and satisfying. And then he just gets up there and rocks out. And it's so cool and satisfying. And then he has a talking head where he explains that he is himself basically. He is Creed Bretton, member of grassroots.
然后迈克尔试图替补他，他太糟糕了。然后克里德说，让我试试。然后他就在那里摇滚起来。太酷了，太令人满足了。然后他有一个谈话头（采访），解释说他基本上就是他自己。他是克里德·布雷顿，草根乐队的成员。
And that he kind of fried his brain with drug use. Now he can barely concentrate on his job. And then there's a talking head of Angela going, he wasn't that good or something like that. I've seen better. Oh man. By the way, I would wear a shirt that says, I'd saved the receptionist. I think that is-
而且他因为吸毒把脑子烧坏了。现在他几乎无法专注于工作。然后有一个安吉拉的谈话头说，他没那么好之类的。我见过更好的。哦，伙计。顺便说一句，我会穿一件写着“我会救前台”的衬衫。我觉得那……
We should have shirts that say, I'd saved the receptionist. I think that's so cute. I think Ken did a really good job with that too, because that was, I believe, supposed to just be a talking head. And he- Yes, in the script, it's a talking head.
我们应该有写着“我会救前台”的衬衫。我觉得那太可爱了。我认为肯在那方面也做得很好，因为那，我相信，本来应该只是一个谈话头。他……是的，在剧本里，它是一个谈话头。
Yeah. And he really rightly said, well, where exactly did he say this? Cause he, you know, he had the thought and then he walks over to Pam and then she gets interrupted by Roy setting a date. So he couldn't figure out where there was gonna be a time to interview him about this.
是啊。他非常正确地说，好吧，他到底在哪里说的这个？因为他，你知道，他有了这个想法，然后他走向帕姆，然后她被罗伊定日期打断了。所以他想不出哪里会有时间采访他关于这件事。
And so he, it sort of invented this on the fly interview where he kind of just passed the cameraman and set it into camera then. And it was cool. Yeah, I really liked that. No, and you're with him. Like Jim's got his courage. He's gonna save the receptionist.
所以他，它有点即兴发明了这个采访，他有点只是经过摄像师，然后对着镜头说了。这很酷。是啊，我真的很喜欢那个。不，而且你和他在一起。就像吉姆鼓起了勇气。他要救前台。
He almost gets up to Pam. And that's when Roy stands up and says that he's setting a wedding date, June 10th. A fan question from Ed's art quizza said, was Pam genuinely happy when Roy proposed or was she just caught up in the moment? Well, I looked at the script. The script said, Pam looks happy.
他差点走到帕姆身边。就在那时，罗伊站起来说他要定一个婚礼日期，6月10日。一位粉丝Ed's art quizza问，帕姆在罗伊求婚时是真的开心，还是她只是被那一刻冲昏了头？嗯，我看了剧本。剧本说，帕姆看起来很开心。
So I played it that Pam was genuinely kind of overcome with this moment. You know, she's been trying to get Roy's attention. I think she wants him to treat her like this so badly. And so she's also invested years into this relationship. I feel like I feel for her because she's like, all right, we're going to we're going to do it. This is it.
所以我演的是帕姆真的有点被那一刻淹没了。你知道，她一直试图引起罗伊的注意。我想她非常希望他这样对待她。所以她也在这段关系中投入了多年。我觉得我为她感到难过，因为她就像，好吧，我们要……我们要做了。就是这个。
Yeah, I think it makes it so much worse, too, because he had his moment on the deck. Yeah. and she was quite receptive there and then he didn't go for anything. And then here, look how happy she is that she finally, after three years of being strung along, and then you could just picture like, oh, maybe I could have made that face on her if I'd said something upstairs. Yes. It's heartbreaking.
是啊，我觉得这让情况变得更糟了，因为他在甲板上有过他的时刻。是啊，而且她在那里相当接受，然后他什么都没做。然后在这里，看她有多开心，在被吊了三年胃口之后，你就能想象，哦，如果我在楼上说了什么，我可能也能让她露出那种表情。是的。太令人心碎了。
And then he's mean to Katie. Well, Amy's, first of all, Amy's reaction is so sweet. So sweet. She is, I mean, she's waiting for her moment. Please propose to her somebody because she's like, oh my God, this is amazing. Amazing. And then you're right, Jim breaks up with Katie, very abruptly,
然后他对凯蒂很刻薄。嗯，艾米的，首先，艾米的反应太甜了。太甜了。她，我的意思是，她在等她的时刻。求求谁向她求婚吧，因为她就像，哦天哪，这太棒了。太棒了。然后你是对的，吉姆和凯蒂分手了，非常突然，
Jibbity Jenkins actually wrote in. Jibbity Jenkins. That's not a real name. Come on. First, it's not real. Also, you just rolled into it. I thought it was part of your sentence. You're like, and then Katie, Jibbity Jenkins. I was like, is this a close word? That's like a Missouri thing, right? Probably Jibbity Jenkins. From Dogpatch, Jibbity Jenkins. Jibbity Jenkins says, Jim was kind of a dick to Katie,
Jibbity Jenkins真的写信进来了。Jibbity Jenkins。那不是一个真实的名字。得了吧。首先，它不是真的。而且你刚才顺口说了出来。我以为那是你句子的一部分。你就像，然后凯蒂，Jibbity Jenkins。我就想，这是一个密语吗？那就像密苏里州的东西，对吧？可能是Jibbity Jenkins。来自Dogpatch，Jibbity Jenkins。Jibbity Jenkins说，吉姆对凯蒂有点混蛋，
the entire cruise for no reason, other than he wanted to be with Pam. She's really innocent through all this. And then he just breaks up with her. Also don't break up with someone on a boat. Well, yeah. A lot of the writers said that too, to me. And I thought it was the most efficient breakup you could possibly have, pretty much.
整个游轮期间无缘无故，除了他想和帕姆在一起。她在这整件事中真的很无辜。然后他就和她分手了。而且不要在船上和人分手。嗯，是啊。很多编剧也对我这么说。我觉得这是你可能有的最高效的分手，差不多。
And we always had time issues. And I just didn't really want to see a long drawn out scene with Katie. And it just wasn't about that. And it seemed to me he was motivated to be brusque and. He was really upset. He was hurting. He was hurting and he just sort of lashed out. I didn't think it needed to be long.
而且我们总是有时间问题。我真的不想看到和凯蒂的一场冗长的戏。那不是关于那个的。在我看来，他有动力变得生硬和……他真的很沮丧。他在受伤。他在受伤，他只是有点发泄。我不认为它需要很长。
I thought it was perfect, but I also love, and this is something we've talked about a lot, Greg, is that these characters are flawed people. They're not perfect people. So they're going to have moments like Pam was petty. I think Pam has been petty. And my character is certainly, we've talked about my character is certainly, you know, not the nicest person. You went the longest being not the nicest of any character. Yes. And which was great because then when we got into season nine and I was kind of casting about
我觉得它很完美，但我也喜欢，这是我们谈论过很多次的事情，格雷格，这些角色是有缺陷的人。他们不是完美的人。所以他们会有时刻，就像帕姆很小气。我认为帕姆一直很小气。而我的角色当然，我们谈过我的角色当然，你知道，不是最友善的人。你做了最长时间不是任何角色中最友善的。是的。这很棒，因为当我们进入第九季，我有点在寻找
for what the arc of season nine should be, it was like, well, there's only one character left who hasn't warmed up at all. Let's put Angela through hell this year. And let her soften just a smidge. Let her deserve a happy ending. Yeah. So then we have a scene where we see that Captain Jack and Meredith are sneaking away to make out, get it on something. Meredith's going to come back later without a shirt on and just a life preserver.
第九季的弧线应该是什么，就像，好吧，只剩下一个还没暖起来的角色了。今年让安吉拉经历地狱吧。让她稍微软化一点。让她值得一个幸福的结局。是啊。所以我们有一场戏，我们看到杰克船长和梅雷迪斯溜走去亲热，搞点什么。梅雷迪斯后来会回来，没穿衬衫，只戴着救生圈。
Do you remember the letter her dad wrote her? Do you remember that letter? Yeah. That said, Dear Kate, stop taking your clothes off. Thanks, dad. Yes. Well, this gives Michael the opening to take the microphone and really start his presentation,
你还记得她爸爸写给她的那封信吗？你还记得那封信吗？是啊。上面写着，亲爱的凯特，别再脱衣服了。谢谢，爸爸。是的。嗯，这给了迈克尔机会去拿麦克风，真正开始他的演讲，
which he does by announcing that the ship is sinking. Most of the people don't realize that this is a metaphor, passengers panic, and a man jumps overboard. JT wrote in to ask who was the actual person who jumped in the water? And a lot of people are asking what happened to that person? Yes, well that was one of the non-Dunder Mifflin people
他通过宣布船正在下沉来做到这一点。大多数人没有意识到这是一个比喻，乘客恐慌，一个人跳下船。JT写信问谁是那个真正跳进水里的人？很多人在问那个人发生了什么？是的，好吧，那是船上非邓德·米夫林的人之一。
on the boat. And as I recall, he was not supposed to jump off the boat. As I recall, I mean, I may be blowing this because it was a while ago, but I think there was a little bit of shock that one of the extras jumped off the boat in that take. And I think we were probably not supposed to let him jump off the boat.
据我回忆，他不应该跳下船。据我回忆，我的意思是，我可能在吹牛，因为那是很久以前的事了，但我认为那次拍摄中有一个临时演员跳下船，大家有点震惊。我想我们可能不应该让他跳下船。
Oh my God. Well, on the DVD commentary, Greg, you said he really jumped out of the window into the freezing cold water. Yeah. And you said that you always felt bad that there is no, like this person jumped into the- It wasn't on camera. It wasn't on camera.
天哪。嗯，在DVD评论里，格雷格，你说他真的从窗户跳进了冰冷的水里。是啊。你说你一直觉得很糟糕，因为没有……就像这个人跳进了……它不在镜头里。它不在镜头里。
He didn't jump in a boat. He didn't jump in a boat. Like he had to be fished out of the water. There could have been just a rubber dingy there. I believe it only happened the one time. Yeah, I think so. I think he may have either misinterpreted some direction or he just was super enthusiastic. I have a slight memory of that being a little too gorilla. That's like Kent was out there running that shot, Kent's before that. Kent was in the boat that was supposed to catch him, but he went and took the shot.
他没有跳进船里。他没有跳进船里。就像他必须被从水里捞出来。那里可能只有一艘橡皮艇。我相信它只发生过一次。是啊，我想是这样。我想他可能要么误解了一些指示，要么他只是超级热情。我有一点记忆，那有点太游击了。就像肯特在外面运行那个镜头，肯特·兹博纳克。肯特在应该接住他的船上，但他去拍那个镜头了。
Well, I loved it. So this is around 17 minutes, 34 seconds for my time code people, but I love that the Dunder Mifflin employees know immediately that there's no emergency. And like even like Kevin and Angela, like we're in a booth together. Oscar I guess is off somewhere being snarky. And we're like, no, no guys Angela, like we're in a booth together, Oscar, I guess, is off somewhere being snarky. And we're like, no, no, guys, no, no, there's nothing. Right. You're trying to calm it down. Yeah. Yeah. And you pan across all the different Dunder Mifflin employees and they're like,
嗯，我很喜欢。所以这大约是17分34秒，对于我的时间码观众来说，但我喜欢邓德·米夫林的员工立即知道没有紧急情况。就像凯文和安吉拉，我们在一起，奥斯卡我想在某处刻薄。我们就像，不，不，伙计们，安吉拉，我们在一起，奥斯卡我想在某处刻薄。我们就像，不，不，伙计们，不，不，什么都没有。对吧。你在试图让它平静下来。是啊。是啊。你扫视所有不同的邓德·米夫林员工，他们就像，
oh God, here we go. But the rest of the boat doesn't know. Well, this, oh, go ahead. What are you going to say? Well, I'm just saying this was leading up to him being handcuffed on the roof. Yes. Yes. And the kind of secret impetus for this whole episode was that we had come on the air in the first season and we were given six episodes and we didn't do a great job in the ratings.
哦天哪，又来了。但船上的其他人不知道。嗯，这，哦，继续。你要说什么？嗯，我只是说这导致他在屋顶上被戴上手铐。是的。是的。而这一整集的秘密推动力是，我们在第一季播出，我们被给了六集，我们在收视率上做得不是很好。
And there was a lot of question whether we'd get invited back. And so at one point in between the seasons, Kevin Riley said, come in and pitch me a new take on the show, why should I bring you guys back? Oh my gosh, pressure. There was a lot of pressure. And so I had initially kind of thought that The Office was such a special, unique show, which I had so much respect for
而且有很多问题我们是否会被邀请回来。所以有一次在两季之间，凯文·赖利说，进来给我推销一个关于这部剧的新视角，为什么我应该带你们回来？天哪，压力。压力很大。所以我最初有点认为《办公室》是一部如此特别、独特的剧，我非常尊重它
that I wouldn't change very much on it. And I realized that I needed to change something. And I had some experience with this, with King of the Hill, in making Hank likable, the lead of King of the Hill. And he has certain qualities that were invented to keep him likable. And so I was like, oh, this isn't really that different, because Michael has some negative qualities
我不会改变太多。但我意识到我需要改变一些东西。我在这方面有一些经验，在《山丘之王》中，让汉克变得讨人喜欢，作为《山丘之王》的主角。他有一些为了让他讨人喜欢而发明的特质。所以我当时想，哦，这其实没什么不同，因为迈克尔有一些负面特质
and I just gotta find a way to give him some stories that are gonna warm him up. And so I wrote out a bunch of story ideas somewhere, like in probably in Norms, no, we weren't at Norms yet. That was my go-to place in the mornings on Sherman Way in Woodman. But yeah, so I was in some coffee shop and I wrote down a bunch of moments
我只需要找到一种方法给他一些故事，让他暖起来。所以我写下了一堆故事点子，在某个地方，比如可能在Norms，不，我们还没去Norms。那是早晨我在谢尔曼大道和伍德曼路上的首选之地。但是的，所以我在某个咖啡店，我写下了一堆时刻
that I thought would warm them up. And one of them was that, for instance, that even though the staff finds him irritating, they'll back him against an outsider. So that was like the end of Dundee's. And one of them was like, he should be good at his job, which happened in the client. He actually was a good salesperson. And this one was that he should give a piece of really good advice to somebody that the audience was going to be happy that that advice
我认为会让他们暖起来。其中之一是，例如，即使员工觉得他很烦人，他们也会支持他对抗外人。所以那是《邓迪奖》的结尾。其中之一是，他应该擅长他的工作，这发生在《客户》中。他确实是一个好的销售员。而这一集是，他应该给某人一些非常好的建议，观众会很高兴那个建议
was transferred, you know, and you'd be like, yeah, good for you, Michael. And so it was sort of all about him telling Jim to never give up on the top of that thing. BFD. Yeah, BFD, right? Engaged Ain't Married. Yeah. But that's what the audience wanted to see.
被传达了，你知道，你会觉得，是啊，为你高兴，迈克尔。所以这基本上是关于他在船顶上告诉吉姆永远不要放弃。BFD（大不了）。是啊，BFD，对吧？订婚了又没结婚。是啊。但这就是观众想看到的。
Jim was so sad. You wanted somebody to give him some hope and keep this Jim Pam thing going. And so Michael kind of stepped in and I took the never, ever, ever give up from actually the Winston Churchill speech, which was too- This is perfectly you. This is so nerdy of me, right?
吉姆当时太难过了。你希望有人能给他一些希望，让吉姆和帕姆这段感情继续下去。所以迈克尔介入了，我从温斯顿·丘吉尔的演讲中借用了“永不、永不、永不放弃”这句话，这太……这太适合你了。我这样是不是太书呆子气了？
This is perfectly you. Yeah. But like I always choke up at the speeches of Winston Churchill in World War II and you know fight him on the beaches You know and he has something where he says never ever ever ever given, you know, and I was like, that's cool I'm gonna crib that for Well, it worked and it also worked for me but like on a different level for Michael like it works for Jim But for Michael the whole, he just wanted someone to feel inspired by him. Yeah, that too.
这太适合你了。是的。但我总是会被温斯顿·丘吉尔在二战期间的演讲所打动，你知道的，在海滩上战斗……他有一段话是说永不、永不、永不放弃，你知道的，我就想，这太酷了，我要把它借用到……好吧，它奏效了，对我来说也奏效了，但对迈克尔来说是另一个层面，它对吉姆有效。但对迈克尔来说，他只是想让别人因为他而感到受鼓舞。是的，那也是。
So when Roy announces the engagement, he was like, is this because of the talk you and I had? And he goes, no, Captain Jack. And he's like, so you see Jim's appreciation in this moment. And I feel like Michael feels it. And I'm like, oh, Michael got one person. Yeah, it was great because the two plots kind of intersect there for a moment. And when Jim first walks up to Michael as an audience member, I'm thinking, oh gosh, this is the worst person for him to be around right now. He is so vulnerable. This is bad. And then it turns into what it is. And it's perfect. So after a few of those, It's perfect. So perfect.
所以当罗伊宣布订婚时，他问，这是因为我和你谈过的话吗？他说，不，杰克船长。所以你看到了吉姆在那一刻的感激之情。我觉得迈克尔也感受到了。我就想，哦，迈克尔终于影响了一个人。是的，这太棒了，因为这两个情节在那一刻交织在了一起。当吉姆第一次以观众的身份走向迈克尔时，我在想，天哪，他现在最不该接触的就是这个人。他太脆弱了。这太糟糕了。然后它变成了现在的样子。这太完美了。所以在那几次之后，这太完美了。太完美了。
After a few of those, Michael starts to get to be a better lead. Well, guys, we did it. We did it. Greg, thank you so much. I want to give a plug. You have a new show coming up called Upload, which premieres on Amazon Prime this April.
在那几次之后，迈克尔开始成为一个更好的领导者。好吧，伙计们，我们做到了。我们做到了。格雷格，非常感谢你。我想做个宣传。你有一部新剧即将上映，叫《上载新生》，将于今年四月在亚马逊Prime首播。
This is crazy. This is the first show that you have written since you wrote The Finale of the Office. That's correct. I've been working on this for so long. It's kind of ridiculous. We had our strike in 2008 and this was my sort of idea to write a book, like a sci-fi book. Okay.
这太疯狂了。这是你自写完《办公室》大结局以来创作的第一部剧。没错。我为此工作了太久了。这简直有点荒谬。我们在2008年经历了罢工，这就是我当时想写书的念头，就像一本科幻小说。好的。
And then we went back to work. And so, you know, it was gestating for a long time and it's sort of a romance, very intense, and it's set in the future. And I am in, I am in, I love sci-fi, I am so in. Well, it's got a very kind of accessible, more Harry Potter-y than like on a spaceship kind of deal. And yeah, and anyway, so I had been working on it pretty much since the office went down, which is ridiculous, but I wrote it, I sold it to HBO. It was there for a couple of years and then it went over to Amazon and we shot it in Vancouver
然后我们回去工作了。所以，你知道，它酝酿了很长时间，它有点像浪漫剧，非常激烈，背景设定在未来。我加入，我加入，我喜欢科幻，我太想看了。好吧，它有一种非常平易近人的感觉，比那种在宇宙飞船上的故事更像《哈利·波特》。总之，我基本上从《办公室》结束后就开始写它了，这很荒谬，但我写完了，把它卖给了HBO。它在那里待了几年，然后转到了亚马逊，我们在温哥华拍摄了它
at the beginning of the year and yeah, it's finally coming out. I can't wait to see it. I love all of this. These are like some of my favorite movies. And it's a comedy. Yeah, it's funny too. It's a comedy.
在年初，是的，它终于要上映了。我迫不及待想看了。我喜欢所有这些。这些是我最喜欢的电影类型。而且这是一部喜剧。是的，它也很有趣。这是一部喜剧。
It's like a lot of stuff. There's a mystery. There's, it's basically, there's this idea that in the future, medical imagery will get much better and virtual reality and it'll become possible if you're in an accident and you get to the hospital in time to have your brain scanned and then you can be uploaded, it's called upload, into a virtual reality hotel
它包含了很多东西。有一个谜团。基本上，有一个想法是，在未来，医学影像技术会变得更好，虚拟现实技术也会进步，如果你发生事故并及时赶到医院进行大脑扫描，那么你就可以被上传——这就是为什么叫《上载新生》——到一个虚拟现实酒店里
that's run by all the big tech companies. So the six big tech companies that have things like Alexa and Siri, they have programmed these luxurious sort of virtual hotels along the lines of different themes. So like the Facebook one is like a casino and the Apple one is like some sort of beachy kind of resort. And the one that he ends up being uploaded in is like this mountain hotel on a lake and
由所有大型科技公司运营。所以那六家拥有Alexa和Siri等产品的大型科技公司，他们根据不同的主题编程了这些豪华的虚拟酒店。比如Facebook的就像一个赌场，苹果的就像某种海滩度假村。而他最终被上传到的那个，就像是一个湖边的山间酒店，并且
Anyway, that's now did his body die, but then yes upload his brain was a spoiler. No, his brain was scanned No, I know but I'm saying is it's your head it burns your head off when when the scan when the scan happened So you have died in the real world and now you live out as an upload. But the information exists and it's digitally presented in a piece of software so that you think you're still alive. I love it, I love it. Upload on Amazon, I can't wait. In April.
总之，现在他的身体死了吗，然后是的，上传他的大脑是个剧透。不，他的大脑被扫描了。不，我知道，但我想说的是，这是你的头，当扫描发生时，它会烧掉你的头。所以你在现实世界中已经死了，现在你作为上传者生活。但信息存在，并以软件的形式呈现，让你以为自己还活着。我喜欢，我喜欢。亚马逊上的《上载新生》，我迫不及待了。在四月。
So yeah guys, if you want more from the man who gave you the office, you have to check out Upload. Yay, Greg, if you want more from the man who gave you The Office, you have to check out Upload. Thanks Greg. Thank you so much. What a pleasure. Thank you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniela Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis.
所以，伙计们，如果你想从那个带给我们《办公室》的人那里看到更多作品，你一定要看看《上载新生》。耶，格雷格，如果你想从那个带给我们《办公室》的人那里看到更多作品，你一定要看看《上载新生》。谢谢格雷格。非常感谢。很高兴。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯酒》。本集最初是与Earwulf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。
Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。